[Music]
[Music]
look what I become
[Music]
yeah
all right so episode number what are we
on uh Rock 228 wow with uh a be back
with a be back now Adam's a Vinnie by
the way thank you for turning Vinnie's
mic off you know what I appreciate your
hooray in the back they shut mine okay
you're back so baby for two hours no but
anyways Brian Callan is back on the
podcast
what does that mean
you're getting hit dude do you really
speak Russian I know who said I spoke I
know I know what means good but that's
all I know what languages do you speak
English
yes
sorry guys I I go I go that easily into
French yeah now I speak German or no no
I wish I spoke Spanish yeah
according to the bio there was Russian
there is that where you're going yeah
yeah we also do walking but that might
be that might be me lying when people
say what do you do and I say things like
I'm half Cherokee you know all this
stuff well back in the day I used to say
whatever
by the way how was your visit to Davos
World economic Forum what was it like
tell us about it I was curious well um
what's the climate like any and like to
do we met in the middle of the Arctic
and and that's all by the way you'll
find out you'll find out did you see did
you have you seen okay so for the people
that are on we got a lot of things we
want to go through Stephen Crowder we
saw what happened with them in Daily
wires reaction maybe we'll talk about
that uh anti-aging have you seen the new
thing that came up I haven't seen the
new thing I've been following this I
have friends who are obsessed with the
longevity thing yeah yeah you know and
my thing is you want to live past 100
you ever see what 100 year old person
looks like yeah they look like the kind
of person the kind of thing you put on a
porch at Halloween it doesn't get better
than that it's not like you're 100 and
you go can't wait to live another 20
years and look like this by the way
Band-Aids on their face imagine can you
imagine the guys at Davos everybody's
like I said have you guys already
figured it out or no we need that
anti-aging stuff like right away because
it's only got to be for us right yeah
yeah did you guys hear about the Beyonce
24 million dollar deal or no for one
hour
24 million for one hour wow and then I'm
sure you guys have a lot of feedback and
commentary on the new beautiful Martin
Luther King statue which is just the
work of art you know it reminded me of
David Beckham when he was first gifted
the fake Statue and it was like a prank
my God they were playing on him I don't
know if you've seen that it's sick I
haven't seen this new and then and then
we got Facebook and Instagram officially
I know you were very happy about this
that Naples are now now you play nipples
and I got banned for doing something
whatever yeah so so again a lot of stuff
going on but did you see did you see the
speeches at Davos I didn't see I've
watched some of it you know my thing
about Davos and and all of this is it
anytime you get people who have gotten
to where they've gotten yeah
there becomes this idea that here we are
the philosopher Kings and we are going
to remake Society on our own philosophy
for King yeah well that's that's really
what the Republic was about and that
that's something that all of us have to
avoid there's this tendency as soon as
you get into a position of power or
whatever you're doing that a little
smarter than uh the masses the average
and I think everyone has that that's
what the founding fathers in this
country warned us about it's very easy
it's very easy to think that we because
we're educated we know what's powerful
better for you and here's why I I think
the biggest threat is you can't read
about life and hear about life and
understand life there's a there's a
there's a thing you get when you're an
entrepreneur and you had to build a
business from the beginning because you
make all these mistakes and more
importantly you have to be in tune with
relationships and people you you should
know people that work with their hands
you should know people who are in the
military you should know people who
listen to sports radio
because those are the people that keep
things running and they understand you
should know people who know how to grow
things in the ground you know the the
the coats are very condescending to the
flyover states but the coast would
starve without the flyover states do you
know much about moisture and and how to
how to predict rainfall and when to lay
your crops there are a thousand things
that a farmer or somebody who gets their
hands dirty knows that somebody who has
their PHD in comparative literature in
Boston at one of our Elite universities
will never touch and that's a very
important thing to understand and here's
the biggest reason the people who at
Davos are Think Tank wonks
economists are academics usually
including politicians but but also
journalists especially the ones you hear
about they don't pay a price for being
wrong ever okay we do if I don't if I
don't if I'm not funny or I can't keep
things going I don't I don't you know my
show is empty and that's the way it is
and I like the way you're typing you
should always take notes when I talk
and that's called respect everybody's do
you see that if if Patrick does it you
should too yeah yeah man
what you just said is purely what uh
meditations and Marcus Aurelius talks
about in his book is the only thing he
wrote and he talks about that where you
know there's a reason why he was loved
is because he never took himself too
seriously being the guy that he was and
he was the most powerful man in the
world at the time think about that yeah
are you referencing the story we had the
slave follow him around yeah we talked
about this two podcasts if you guys can
just really briefly if for somebody that
doesn't know like Davos says what just
all the smartest people coming up to try
to figure out how to run I love see this
is the people that work with their hands
those are the people that doesn't even
know what Davos give me some coffee yeah
so that is a city in Switzerland yeah
Davos is not a conference it's a city
got you Davos Switzerland and World
economic Forum they get together the
them Klaus Schwab is the founder of
world economic Forum I want to say
started it in the 70s by the way yeah
and he's been at it for a while it had a
complete different name at first it was
called the European something something
Union can you uh World economic Forum uh
if you go uh yeah European management
forum is what it was in 1971 this guy
started it just so you know he started
eight years seven years before you and I
were born six years before you and I
were born so he's been at it for a long
time and somehow someway he has now got
the control and the ears of people like
Justin Trudeau people like Joe Biden
presidents Prime Ministers around the
world that are following his lead okay
his lead in the fact that like World
economic I know it's economic but how to
run dude I just want to meet here this
sounds like a movie just watch 10
seconds of this just to kind of see how
this is my perspective this is
motivational speaking on steroids listen
to what he says okay dear friends
scientifically this is not a climate
crisis we are now facing something
deeper mass extinction air pollution
undermining ecosystem functions mass
extinction really putting Humanity's
future at risk this is a planetary
crisis
pause it okay so this is sharing the
[ __ ] out of people number one that's
their goal it's a great way to get your
attention 100 we're all gonna die did
you ever go to church did you ever go to
church as a kid where the pastor you
know would baptize in a following way if
you don't give your life to Christ you
will go to hell let me tell you what
hell looks like in hell yeah you'll be
burning your skin the Imagine
temperature fire you're like holy [ __ ]
sauna's hot I don't want you for coming
and you're like you know what I'm gonna
put that water go ahead whatever it is
I'm willing to get baptized in every
possible way so it is a very effective
tactic to get the world moving but they
unify together and they talk about you
know Al Gore said we should spend more
money talking about climate change and
we stop we should start defunding money
that opposes anything with climate
change and some of the stuff they're
talking about you're just like well you
know I think I think it's theatrics and
I think that you know first of all the I
had Peter Zion have you had him on this
podcast I had him on my podcast
everybody's talking dude on my podcast I
read his book and you know he's a global
strategist who he would be hired for
years like so if you wanted to grow
soybeans if you had a company that grew
soybeans you wanted to know he he knows
the moisture the rainfall in Brazil he
knows everything about everything when
it comes to the minutia and he was
breaking down the fact that if you think
we're off fossil fuels if you think that
any of these countries are going to go
it with just solar or uh Hydro or
whatever it is that's adorable that's
actually adorable it's adorable you
think our agricultural session you think
you're going to grow food without you
need irrigation guess what you need a
gasoline to to pump those fields you
need for herbicides and pesticides those
those are made with natural gas same
with fertilizer I mean our the fossil
fuel print is crazy I I drive around on
a Tesla okay my my when I bought that
car when I bought it the lithium battery
is made on a cold Grid in China when I
bought it before I got into it I had
already polluted it was like driving an
F-150 50 000 55 000 miles yet in
California I get to be in the high
occupancy Lane because I'm not polluting
the environment yeah it's a joke that's
so funny until we come up with what's
going to get us out of this is not not
regulation top-down regulation from the
philosopher Kings what's going to get us
out of this is innovation in Material
Sciences and things like that and again
he's writing things down and it is no
because you just gave me a thought this
one meme that to give a visual to
certain people if we can pull up this
meme uh Brian just made a very good
point so you know this whole thing with
the the the the great uh Greta Thunder
you know yeah
Patrick yeah she's apparently getting an
Oscar and the two German cops got uh uh
Best Supporting play this real quick and
look at how fun she's having look hey
okay let's let's act like I'm getting
arrested yeah hold on wait is that dirt
on his face on purpose look he put coal
on this look how scared she looks she
looks frightened right now you see that
yeah chapped lips get it okay ready
other camera guy make sure the lighting
noise after the roads wet look at that's
they're gripping her really hard yeah
she looks like she looks like she has a
lot of solutions
you know yeah but but you know what the
the fact that this is effective people
all four and she's got six million
Twitter followers oh yeah pause it go to
the meme that uh uh the the meme I just
texted you you'll see it's not on mine
and even crazier the fact that this
video is out we all see it's circulating
people it won't even budge anybody the
real people that believe in they're like
what do you mean she was
dude that thing got 12 million views
that clip got 12 million now watch this
here this is the you're still in my
dreams yeah in my channel
that's the best me my best is that not
the best well that's what that's what
she doesn't understand that's what she
doesn't understand you know and my thing
is that you can Scream and Shout they
can have these theatrical meetings and
things at Davos but at the end of the
day economies are going to do what
economies do and you know I don't that
we don't have right now an alternative
so sorry yeah you mean alternative to
what exactly green green is not here uh
alternative I mean if you talk to people
that really follow this stuff and get
into the minutia you don't want coal
really okay give me are we gonna burn
wood just tell me what we're supposed to
do tell people to stop tell here's the
biggest thing the developing world is
not going to stop being poor because you
want to save trees that's the truth they
they want to keep they want to get out
of their situation you know it's like um
somebody in in uh uh who was it Warren
Buffett's grandson or son Warren Buffett
Warren Buffett gave his son a million
dollars a billion dollars a billion and
said go change the world
and his his son was uh a farmer so he
went to the Congo and uh and he tried to
and I had him on the podcast he tried to
kind of like teach them farming
practices but the Congo had been ravaged
by Civil War of course as We Know and
the guy said to him he said you know and
then they were trying to save gorillas
and stuff and the guy goes my family's
not going to starve for a gorilla and it
sure as heck isn't going to starve for a
tree that's just the way it is you're
not going to stop human beings from
trying to get out of their shitty
situation and
you know so I think the only way to get
out of this is to innovate our way out
of it Innovation is always the way I
don't I just don't I just don't think
that you know you have to have some
legislation of course you have to have
some you know regulation but come on man
at the end of the day it's not going to
get us out of this game let me ask you
guys a question uh this really mostly
for YouTube only because you just found
out about what Davos was about seven
minutes ago so I use these I use my
hands so the whole concept is that it's
a it's these uh it's public-private
Partnerships right so you have
governments and what was it you know
thousands of heads of states or hundreds
of countries heads of sharing ideas like
yeah how do you respond to a pandemic
that's Global things like that well yeah
correct meaning like so you also have
these private companies that I mean I I
tend to trust those companies more than
governments right I mean private
companies corporations care about the
bottom line shareholders so I tend to be
like all right you guys kind of got
something on
um how do you think we've got to the
point where we're only recognizing some
of the negativity surrounding it like
the theatrics but meaning like they like
you don't have an organ I'm not I don't
defend the world that gonna perform this
is just those people are can I get to
the government let me ask you the
question how do we get to the point
where we're not even highlighting any of
the good and do we even know any of the
good that the world economic form has
done you don't do this for 50 years and
do no good question I'm more just
wondering like what have they done you
look at this list of people who are here
this is the who's whose
you don't you don't know them so it's a
party you're not invited to okay party
you don't you're not invited to and they
all get there in their private jets and
they're all powerful people yeah the
idea is how could they ever be up to
something good but it's the same problem
I I have such a problem with when they
demonize somebody like Elon Musk who's a
risk-taking entrepreneur and and there's
this whole thing about if you're if
you're if you're an entrepreneur if you
made a lot of money chances are you took
huge risks chances are you worked I
don't know 18 hours a day for 30 years
chances are you just thought outside the
box and people don't that just reminds
other people of the things they're not
doing yeah and we all have some of that
in so I think sometimes there's a lot of
that although I think a healthy distrust
of powerful people when they get
together and start planning our lives
that's a good thing you know I'm not a
conspiracy theorist but I do think it's
kind of a good thing to kind of worry
about it what are you guys doing there
and why are you making rules that I have
like what about my voice you know that
kind of stuff and that's why I think the
the point you made at the onset of the
podcast was so powerful is that you have
these elites on the coast that's just in
America yeah now extrapolate that to the
world yeah the elites of the world
making decisions for the farmer or the
mechanic or the comedian using his hands
like yeah that that I think is
ultimately your point is that why it's
like such negative disdain at these
people but if you look at the list it's
like I'd like to know the names of the
people that are there to hold them
accountable like this I don't the cloud
shop seems like the like if you if
Austin Powers was written in real life
and they're like who do you want to play
Dr Evil
that German accent I'm a German people
very yeah I want to make everybody a
machine yes yes
so him he talked about this Pat like
what a horrible like you know face for a
company but if you look at these people
that are there these are actually the
people movers and shakers you would hope
trying to help the world it's just I
think they do I think I don't think
they're out to destroy the world I think
everybody wants to create the world in
their own image I mean I'm sorry but the
the Iraq War was that you had a group of
people who most had never been to the
Middle East certainly didn't speak
Arabic didn't know much about the didn't
know even the difference between a Sunni
and a Shia yeah and had the hubris to
think they could restructure the Middle
East right Babylon Iraq been around 5
000 years that's a large historical
footprint but we're going to come along
and restructure your country and it
didn't go that well no but that's
what is the list by the way can we see
the name you keep hiding the names at
the top I I I'm thinking like Robin well
these are Tony John Kerry Tony Blair
keep going up let's see horses achieve
uh secret intelligence
[Laughter]
Rob you're going the other way I mean
you're looking at London I saw Joe
manchin Kristen Cinema these are U.S
senators
governor of Georgia Beyonce okay
Beyonce's in Dubai that's the whole keep
going up keep going up keep going up
keep going up keep going up let's see
who's pritzker the governor of uh
Illinois right minister of uh State
Finance Affairs then you see a lot of
ahmeds in Muhammad oh a lot of Abdullah
oh yeah that's serious yeah a lot of
them there's some money up there guys
one guy gives is given a speech and he
says
um
he says look am I going to be the only
one person that's going to talk about uh
we're going to get together a world
economic forum and we're going to talk
about climate change but nobody wants to
talk about billionaires not paying taxes
is that like is that what are we going
to do that are we all going to come at a
meeting like this and no one wants to
pay their fair share of taxes oh great
he said that at the world economic
foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
no you haven't seen it anyways he says
this is that at the world economics
what are you what's your what are your
thoughts honestly look here's I mean
first of all there are no Assyrian names
there so that's a huge problem yeah the
representation for you look no Patrick
we have more ethereum representation
here than anywhere in the world
me and him that's crazy I know that's
true insane dude go to the top of the
list by the way if you don't mind I'll
tell you this my my idea with the with a
meeting like this look at that they have
yeah I mean listen here's all you got to
know every icon pretty much every
country the most powerful people are
there uh Elon Musk is like I'm not going
to a boring meeting like this and they
said oh we haven't invited him since
2015 they bragged about it okay so Elon
Musk because he hasn't been a double
since uh boring his organization is
going to keep going down they said yeah
they're having a vitamins since 2015. so
listen you know they're defending
themselves as well that uh we don't
really want Elon here so if you don't
want Elon there and he's the guy
worldwide doesn't give you a lot lot of
credibility if you're trying to save the
world he's an operator doing it I don't
have a problem with a meeting like this
if there is what debate debate yeah
there is none if you get together and
the panel all agree what the hell are
you getting together for well that's a
huge that's a great point because I I
would say with all these different
people human beings don't agree
right here in this room if we had if I
brought up one subject but greatest
basketball player in the world we'd all
have to forget it yeah so so at the end
of the day people don't agree and you
know you have to worry about you know
one of the things that you know James
Madison when he wrote The Federalist
Papers was all about faction how do we
guard against faction because you have
balance of powers and you break up you
you have checks and balances in
government but it takes one charismatic
leader to get a lot of power and
influence and then and then absorb
another faction and then absorb that
faction pretty soon one guy's
controlling everything that was the
biggest challenge facing that's why
James Madison is a genius and he figured
out a way to avoid that so but I think
in this case you've got people that
don't speak the same language they're
from different countries different
cultures they don't like each other they
have competing interests so the idea
that they're all getting together like
there's this Illuminati you know my
buddy made a lot of money and he he's a
in the banking world and you know and he
he wanted to get this huge fund together
it's so funny and he needed he wanted to
get these six billionaires together
that's all I want to do just in a room
so we can he wanted to create this fun
he had this amazing idea he's made crazy
money he owns you know Banks so he wants
to get these guys he runs in these
circles and because I was talking about
conspiracy he calls me and he goes hey
dude let me explain something to you
okay I tried to get six billionaires
together and I couldn't get them in the
same room because they all hate because
one guy had banged this guy's wife oh
God the other guy had screwed him in a
deal they all hated each other they all
wanted to kill each other so they
weren't going to work together and
that's that probably way more typical
thank God then it's not yeah now there
were Secret pacts in Europe I mean
before we had democracies and stuff a
war would start you wouldn't even know
it was doing because the austral
Hungarian Empire is talking to you know
this group over here and you know they
would create these secret alliances but
I think that that's harder to pull off
now yeah I hope well I think uh the the
banging's definitely going on because
prostitution was on fire Davos it was
twenty five hundred dollars I don't know
if you saw this I did not you didn't see
that yeah
pull up the article sex and the summit
how prostitution blooms during World
economic Forum in Davos I'm outraged
yeah
it's a little turned on sex work gets a
boost like every year if you can go to
the numbers because we like data here
yeah uh so it's only going on a
20-minute report to six worker agents in
our located 100 miles hundreds or
something uh okay there it is to book
one of the sex workers for four hours
her escort company charges around 16 30.
while one night can cost up to 27.70 US
Dollars
well let me write this down
does anybody look down at the I'm not
totally an advocate for this by the way
the go-getters these girls are traveling
all across the world God bless them
getting out there being entrepreneur
saying I gotta go fight you know follow
the money FTM oh these girls are going
after the millionaires when I go after
like the Tom Dick and Harry's the strip
clubs of the world there's no hate
anyway there's a fun fact the oldest
profession in the world as well do you
know prostitution yeah like the oldest
job using your hands we're going through
prostitutes get that money girl get that
back but good for listen I'm good for
them is there a possible way to find out
I'm telling you you're such small
thinkers why prostitutes are small
thinkers why what would you do first of
all if you're if you're a prostitute
asking for that kind of money what does
that mean the only reason somebody would
pay 27.70 for a night is you have to be
hot oh ain't nobody paying 27.70 so if
you are part of a small percentage of
women in the world that are hot 20 grand
you're only taking 27 7 what a small
thinker you are go to Palm Beach go to
at a restaurant called Meat Market yeah
and finally stay at the bar I guarantee
you show up for 90 days
you will lock up a billionaire okay 100
that's the small thing motivational
quotes a lot of them do I think if
they're smart but sometimes they've just
got a disaster for a personality I would
imagine that's harder easier said than
done because billionaires a lot of times
are smart too and they're like you know
I'm not here for your person but the
billionaires did what happens to them is
when the blood circulates in different
aspects of their body yeah they're not
that smart you know so sometimes you
know history has proven that sometimes
we don't make the best decisions
obviously none of us here have ever we
are very one very focused groups
that's right well but maybe the
prostitutes need like an entrepreneur
like imagine Pat being that like the
leader of them like how their business
would [ __ ] oh my God can you be doing
no what would happen to be jailed away
yeah
let me I'll take that back yeah worth it
no I mean you would be the perfect I
would it would be professional and they
would dude it would be a billion dollars
ladies we got to think big but I think
it's too small I'm actually being very
very serious what percentage let's let's
play a game here okay what percentage of
men would you say are eight or higher in
looks eight or higher in the world in
this room yeah you get lost in my eyes
yeah I'm talking symmetry or are you
talking about shoulders okay okay let me
show you what I'm worth it's great shape
thank you maybe a twirl next time yeah
yeah different podcast different podcast
at least one out of the four let's say
what I'm used to doing the ones uh
podcast yeah
what are you talking about good looking
guys okay so first of all Define good
looking guys look at all the guys in
this room we're all good looking okay so
what is Adam what does Adam and looks
let's not go here I have I have been I
have been driving I humping him with my
eyes since I got in this room I'm giving
Adam a solid a solid eight okay
by the way by the way I'm being so
serious with you tell me what percentage
20 I think it's less it's probably less
but I'd say this I'd say 20 if you look
at like there are men that are athletic
enough I'm going to give it a 20 it
depends on where but guys who work out
that in this in this let's just take
let's take Southern Florida
where you can or California I mean it
depends on where you're at I think it is
20 I was in I was in Fort Wayne Indiana
yeah yeah and by the way you know what I
would you know I I have I have a major
pushback let me let me tell you okay but
but here's how I process it what is an
eight let's define in it is it just fit
like total past you said looks though
that's why I was going to be bluish
Better Way what percentage of the men
actually get laid can date where where
where they can go on a dating app and
women swipe whatever less than 20 I
think less than 20. I'm gonna say it's
20. yes less than twenty twenty or less
yeah higher than 15. 80 20. about 20
because otherwise they wouldn't be
making this kind of money and it
wouldn't be said because women are not
as ruthless and physical as men in terms
of when they're looking for a mate
sometimes the guy can be if he's got if
he's wealthy if he's driven ambitious
great personality those things get you
ahead man though that's a different
thing you know like there are a lot of
guys that aren't uh that might be a six
five on paper but they're killing it
because they've they've just got it
they're good they're a boss so that's a
better idea I would say it's still 20
where I'm going with this where I'm
going with this is so it looks alone is
not going to get you uh uh uh you know
what you want right so you can still
have the looks and screw up and not use
the looks that was gifted to you because
you didn't do anything about the looks
that's purely genetics right yeah okay
then comes what then comes you know
market value what you make your you know
purchasing power whatever you want to
call that you're making good money
you're making good earnings then it's
your body you take care of your health
there's a lot of guys that have good
looking faces but they don't take care
of their health their body so they're
not you know they're you know not in
good shape and then there's
communication persuasion you know
telling jokes being witty being
complimentary being curious that's a
complete different skill set that you
have but when it comes down to you know
women if you have the percentage okay
put the percentage for women as well
eight or higher what do you think it is
oh that's way you're going to say same
percentage no way I think it's more I
think women now have technology it's
like and they've always assessment yeah
I mean if I'm if I don't if I'm not a
good looking guy I can wear a shiny
shirt bro and have a nice watch there's
an industry there's a medical industry
and a fashion industry dedicated to
creating Illusions so that you look like
you cut light well I don't have those
options man right you know what I'm
saying I mean I do obviously but you
know but you know what I'm saying yeah
so so but but I would say honestly women
think about it like the like when when
you're at a bar but that's not a good
metric Taste of prostate prostitution is
a yeah cause you're about to make a
point we want to make a point off your
of your number no no because the whole
concept of prostitution is you know when
we were in the Army there was this strip
club down the from Fort Campbell
Kentucky we had this one guy at the the
unit every month he was broke so finally
one of the roommates were like dude this
guy's an E4 he's making 1500 bucks a
month okay why is he broke at the end of
the month he had this one stripper he
would go to and he was kind of she she
promised him she loved him and she
wanted to marry him never kissed never
had nothing wow but you have to realize
he was a four though yeah yeah but she
was a eight a nine that convinced him
and he Pro she probably had 10 of them
so she's making 10 a month at
Clarksville every month he would give
her a thousand dollars okay so if you're
making 10 grand a month in Clarksville
dude you're rolling I don't know if
you've been to Clarksville there's
nothing you're the mayor yeah yeah
you're the mayor give her a grandma a
grand a month and his income was 1500
we're like how are you this bro he never
got laid never got laid never once got
two years never got late so he got he by
the way not just late nothing he didn't
get laid but he got [ __ ] yeah
you're right basically he did There's is
a technical term for that type of guy
he's called a simp
or a mark that's for sure I just can I
just weigh in on this a little bit uh
regard to that but you think this you
can see how Pat thinks now I was like
how do we get these strippers from
thinking like entrepreneurs it's like
it's cause and effect there's a reason
that they ended up in this line of work
because they probably weren't making the
best decisions sure and like and
whatever code of shortcuts in life but
to your point there's something called
the sexual market value yeah there's pie
charts to this and it's essentially what
Pat was talking about within men how
women perceive men there's an equitable
distribution in how they perceive men
right so there's the two larger parts of
the pie chart it's resources and Status
women are attracted to powerful men
right so if you look at resources and
Status that's 50 of it then you have
personality in game that's another 25
and then looks in age another 25 so
there's this full package that women are
looking for in a man surrounding
basically game looks and money and
wealth Empower and resources now
conversely to to your point if you go on
to what uh men look for in women there's
another chart right there it's all red
the bottom right go right below it right
boom 80 looks 80 80 looks meaning I
don't give a [ __ ] what you do I don't
care how you act yeah it's all that but
then there's sources then there's a 20
20 distribution between age status
personality game so meaning like you're
not gonna bang some old lady because
she's Rich
you're gonna find some homeless girl in
a trash can who's gorgeous and be like
what are you what are you doing in the
trash can you familiar with uh did you
did you call it a book called a billion
Wicked thoughts no oh dude two
neuroscientists from one from Harvard
the other from Boston College these guys
uh I think it was maybe yeah it was true
they got access to pornhub's main server
worldwide oh the back end so they were
literally look at what men looked at oh
my God and women by the way when nobody
else was looking wow okay and dude yeah
I'm like I got a drum roll coming your
way Carolyn Bros what do you tell us so
so the [ __ ] I learned I mean it's like
crazy what men look but but where is so
here's a here's a trivia question where
is gilf porn
where is that the most popular where two
countries countries yeah it's weird gilf
a weird question okay is it a well-known
country or no I think it's America one
is very well known one another is you
know less well-known America's more
America
you want the answer yeah the UK
and Kenya they love old now why why the
queen because because old people a lot
of times are your Headmaster or your
teacher old people tend to take on the
role of teaching young children
you know in in Kenya your grandmother or
an older woman watches the children you
you you imprint your ideas on to that
wow you know but there are a thousand
things so how about this so what is the
we're all men even congenitally blind
men men who are born blind when it comes
to women give me the give me the one
thing and the blind thing is a is a hint
give me the one thing that they all men
it stops all men's their voice your eye
stops you know these a lot of the
feminists are writing about the beauty
myth and it's just like what we've been
told the [ __ ] out of here the [ __ ] out
of here there are certain standards of
beauty that cut across all cultures at
all times what's the one with women like
when you look at a woman what's that
like when I see a girl even a blind guy
yeah even a blind guy that's my my
initial reaction is the voice okay no so
like sometimes just like shut up I like
a deep voice too but no no I was going
the opposite direction boys I didn't
wrap a chick
I got a swimming competition coming up
this week and that's and that's when we
learn Adam was gay
sweaty came out of the closet a lot more
signs before
saying bread comes for years I mean it's
such a weird thing though so it's a hip
to waist ratio but how the hell would
they know they're blind so men when
they're blind men oh they give a hug
when they touch up when they touch a
mannequin lower back it's it's that it's
that deep in the waist so it's it's The
Hourglass thing and for whatever reason
maybe that's where your baby sits right
but all men they we just go right to
that you see somebody built like Boxcar
Willie yeah it ain't gonna I'm not I'm
not spending a lot of my money on that
but but the 2700 I'm spending at Davos
is going to be on that so that's that's
that's another example you got to read
this book I have a question um I already
wrote it because this is your second
time on the podcast pad called you'll be
back in the first 30 minutes yeah you've
quoted Plato I know you're talking James
Madison Federalist Papers you know who
his father was who are you forget what
his dad
said do you know where he was born you
know who this guy is
list and you didn't see it I don't know
what you guys are talking about what's
going on I don't know what you're
talking about
Brian you probably I don't you probably
might have but you might I don't know
you might that might be 50 50. in La
there was this guy going around booking
comedians to go to an island in South
Africa that was owned by a prince uh
Saudi I don't know if you've ever did
the show they fly you the father of the
kidney there well the airplane ride
alone was 10 grand just for us to go
business it was the highest ending I'm
thinking oh you went oh I went with a
couple other you know people come in and
say you know and we go there and we're
performing farmer prints we go in this
room and it's I'm thinking you know 500
people at least all of his rich people
and friends it's us it's a room maybe
four size of this he's in the back with
a little light we're told listen you go
up there you do it's only 30 people in
this room go up there do your jokes
don't look at one don't flirt with no
girls once you're done get on this bus
and leave and this guy flew in 30 of the
they're talking about prostitutes girls
from around the world and he paid them
each 20 grand to come in yeah you
entertained them with the show we all
had to leave because none of us could
flirt and then I knew the security guard
you know he said every hour one girl
would come in boom boom and it was just
a revolving door and I was like yeah
we were in South uh Seychelles South
Africa Little Island oh my God bro and
it was just like we were saying about
money dude 20 grand so for Davao these
people got money who was the guy it
seems very it was a princess I know he
was obviously
but in South Africa in South well
because he owned the resort his name was
Jeffery episode
that makes the most sense to me well in
what way why I think that he he had
enough of these powerful people on uh on
a plane you get him these guys want to
get laid they come to an island now you
got video on these guys I mean I would
imagine if I was uh if I was an
intelligence agency and I wanted
influence it's not a bad way to at least
have something in your back pocket if
you really need a favor yeah did you did
you see the interview with uh Bill
Gates's ex-wife and she was being asked
about hey so
um Melinda you know you you we've read
and you've expressed that one of the
reasons why you know the marriage didn't
work out is the close relationship Bill
had with Jeffrey Epstein was that one of
the reasons she says uh yes
no she said yes she said that was on the
main minutes yeah and then she says she
continues she says what was it that
upsets you about him is it the fact that
he had one too many visits to the island
she pauses she says
um yes but those are questions you're
going to have to ask him yeah so guess
what they do the answer they ask him and
they say so Bill right here do you have
it uh right there just kind of be tough
yeah so watch this I'm not that tough
though because she's crazy Rich she's
awesome
Bill had a friendship or business or
some kind of contact with Jeffrey
Epstein and that you were not uh that
that was very upsetting to you did that
play a role in the in the divorce at all
in this process yeah as I said it's not
one thing it was many things that I did
not like uh that he'd had meetings with
Jeffrey Epstein
and you made that clear to him I made
that clear to him I also met Jeffrey
Epstein exactly one time yes because I
wanted to see who this man was and
um I regretted it from the second I
stepped in the door he was abhorrent he
was evil personified I had nightmares
about it afterwards so you know my heart
breaks for these young women because
that's how I felt and here I'm an older
woman my God I feel terrible for those
young women it's awful you felt that the
moment you walked in I didn't realize
yeah and you shared that with Bill and
he still continued to spend time with
him
any of the questions remaining about
what Bill's relationship there was those
are for Bill to answer okay and I'll
tell you something about women women can
women I believe
can sense a bad dude like that they can
feel it my mother's amazing at that my
mother I'm telling you has antenna my
mother has saved my dad from going into
business deals really dude
she she can look at a dude and go that
guy's a bad guy I got a bad feeling wow
and that's how women had to survive I
think women can pick up on energy that
we don't because we're not afraid I
don't you know I don't walk around
worrying about my physical safety but
there are women I think women are way
better the the Israelis use women as uh
as bodyguards because they found that if
you take you can teach a woman how to
shoot straight no problem and there are
some badass women so they they found
that women they grow up from the age
about 12 years old they have to be I
wait I see it with my daughter they're
very aware of danger they're very aware
why is that guy over there why is he
looking at me for too long what's going
over here they can just sense these
things okay I read um I read I wrote um
a pilot with a woman long time ago who
who was ran a brothel I wanted to do
this thing it was called the rub Club
but she was amazing because she would
say that when they would come in she
would hug a guy so she would hug so the
guy come in hourglass she would hug him
yeah
she would hug him and then her friend
would hug the guy from behind and be
like hi and what they were doing was
checking for weapons wow
right so you push your body against him
make sure he doesn't have a gun or not
because you're gonna get robbed or
whatever that's the first thing they
would do the second thing they would do
is this woman could tell immediately if
this guy's a freak she could tell
immediately if he was dangerous all of
them could because they had so much
experience with this like the way he
walked in was he moving his arms was he
very stiff was his body what was his
body temperature so you know when
somebody like like Melinda Gates sees a
guy like that and she goes I had a bad
feeling man listen to that my mother my
dad was going to go into business with
this guy right and uh you know they're
playing golf and the guy
nobody was looking and he kicked this
ball oh now I cheated golf
all the time and I'm gonna lie about my
score 100 but you're gonna know I'm
lying you're going to see me cheat I'm
not going to actually go I'm not gonna
this guy looked around and just went he
just touched it like that my mother saw
that my mother goes if you put this
money into this deal I'm going to
divorce you what are we talking about
she goes I watched him cheat and he goes
everybody cheats to go off he goes no
nobody cheats when they're really trying
to get away with it anyway long story
short he ended up in jail I'll tell you
oh [ __ ] I think what you're referring to
it you can look at it as women's
intuition they do have that sense and I
think you highlighted it is that as guys
if we're going into business with
somebody or networking somebody's yeah
whatever bro I'm a dude whatever yeah a
girl literally one she walks out the
door like we do the whole okay phone
wallet keys balls got it all right good
to go girl's like all right I got my
mace I've got my purse like there's
another level that women have to go to
for Safety and Security and that
intuition since caveman days has to be a
part of it great point and you know it
yeah here's my question though so she
this this happened fairly recent right
but the Epstein thing he already
killed suicided himself in jail
everything what do you think was her
motivation to finally because dude this
relationship with Epstein was way back
in the day what what do you think was
the the deciding factor for her to say
let me open my mouth now because what
they got galane and she might open her
mouth or what first of all you're
thinking getting a divorce is easy
what do you think a divorce is you think
a divorce is uh like okay yeah you know
no problem like a breakup we're good
we're good score it away yeah all right
all the best to you bro okay tell your
mom awesome loved her cooking but uh I'm
sorry man you know this it is what it is
and my dad's gonna miss you you know he
loves you good luck I'll see you at the
you know whatever casual divorce ever
but but divorces you know take years
before a divorce happens when a divorce
happens a divorce been in the works for
five years okay three years eight years
sometimes ten years right uh uh you know
uh how many times like I'll I'll sit in
over the years we run an insurance
company so we we see a lot of people
being married and some that work
sometimes don't work 22 years you watch
these guys and haven't been married for
13 and a half years myself four kids
families you know that that's a very
hard thing to do but you'll see
if uh there is kids involved if there's
a charity involved and they do there's
you know business involved if there is
uh uh other responsibilities involved if
there are certain legacies involved if
there's dirt on both sides involved if
there is it's it's a very uh it's you
know what it's like it's kind of like a
business partners you start a company
together with your best friend hey
Johnny let's do it 50 50 bro let's go
take over the world awesome
then you start the business
and then six months into it he's like
hey bro just want to let you know I'm
going to take the month of August off
because uh the wife and I we want to go
to such and such what do you mean yeah
bro I mean I'm gonna go dude what are
you talking about we just started the
business I know but it's our business
I'm gonna take all this stuff and then
I'm for Christmas and New Year's we're
going to Davos you know to go there for
vacation so then you're like all right
hey by the way I think uh we need to
hire that two person place you can spend
three hundred thousand dollars so hire
two Executives dude that's a waste of
money why would we do that a year two
years later like oh [ __ ] I made the
biggest mistake of my life your best
friend officially became your best enemy
but try breaking up the 50 50. good luck
you know how many mediations I've done
as a consultant between two business
partners really we had one upstairs just
a couple months ago they're sitting it's
just like a marriage divorce so I said
so can I do something here yes I said
first of all tell me what you respect
and why you guys went into business
together so I write it down you'll feel
the same way yeah okay what got to the
point of you guys not wanting to be in
business together can you tell them
exactly how you feel do you receive it
can you tell them exactly how you found
them boom zero to 100 in no time and
then they're gone they're going they're
going and you got to try to figure out
who bring them down and say can we get
it on paper right now that these are the
terms this is what we're agreeing on
lawyers boom boom boom boom boom you're
hoping one is willing to sell at 1.2
million dollars his shares to the other
again the guy's gonna run with it or hey
I'm Gonna Leave You keep it I'm gonna
start a direct competitor to you and you
cannot come after me and we can and I'm
taking three of the employees you can
keep everybody else it is very very ugly
50 50 Partnerships are very hard to
break apart divorces are the same exact
way so this divorce with Melinda and
Bill probably was in the works for 15
years do you know how they did it do you
know do you know the process I hope I'm
not speaking out a turn but I think I
can say it um so uh his best friend they
got on a boat together all of them all
three of them and with his best friend
and they basically the best friend
mediated the whole thing on a boat in
the middle of the ocean Bill and Melinda
Gates and the best of us correct sir
that is that is
and they just went through the whole
thing I like the way Bezos did it as
well on the same day they tweeted they
said after 25 years we love each other
but at the same time we have grown apart
and we will forever have three things in
common we have our kids and we are going
to run the foundation and we're going to
do this and please respect our personal
life and you know a lot with my marriage
my first marriage like this is the
mother of my children I didn't need a
lawyer I'm going to have we went
literally to arbitration just so we
could figure out but yeah for me I was
like you know you're more important you
and the kids are more important than I
am let's be honest you know what I'm
saying Pat I have an idea yeah speaking
of this arbitration I'm getting to this
like you know by the way we're trying to
get him
are you
dating or you're about to get married
not about to come out Brian thanks for
watching no I'm not saying he's saying
who's the lucky guy the truth is he's
turned on by your voice
but she's picturing you doing the
arbitration like so what are we gonna do
about the airline miles I don't know
maybe I'll take a few you'll take a few
I don't know you're two crazy kids
exactly go ahead and quail it for me
baby just shut your mouth and you're
talking to me I'm just singing the whole
everything with a wedding crash it would
be I would wish I was like a fly on the
boat of the Melinda and the guy and like
just like to a point was like like two
billion more than two billion
billion two billion and like 100 billion
dollars
number like no I want this extra 2
million or no this three billion and
Bill's like listen Melinda you see that
[ __ ] ocean I will you'll be [ __ ]
shark food let's keep it at one but
here's my question though how long has
she been sitting on this not all your
secrets so just for a second
[ __ ] so just for a second 104 billion
I've done this before I've done this
thousand times when you carved up you're
100 billion with your ex yeah yeah that
was really hard for me yeah yeah sure
it's amazing how you've been able to
maintain this uh it's been I'm sorry
yeah I'm so down to Earth but you know
what it is not to me I worked almost
and I charge a lot more than 27 because
I got my manager right here we think big
we do 100 so so 100 billion I I had this
math there's a book and fun book about
this but
um so and I probably said this on the
podcast like I said on every podcast but
every time people bring up a billion how
long is a million seconds and then I'll
ask you how long is a billion seconds
how long your best guess don't don't
worry about it quick guess what do you
think a million seconds a million
seconds is uh
a month good
um a billion seconds a million seconds
yeah I bought them a year about a month
I'll just say three months okay and what
would you say a billion a year a year I
I you don't want me to answer that I
think it's 32 years or some number like
that what is the number you're a
mathematician it's almost 33 years okay
so a billion a million seconds in 11
days
billion a billion seconds she's about 33
years 32 33 years yeah think about the
difference between a million and a
billion that's a second and that's 104.
give you an idea how much money that is
I'm very impressed but I gotta tell you
something about a trillion about it yeah
you're a math guy I sat down with Marcus
and Mark what's the is there is there a
very big difference between being a
millionaire and a billionaire he says
hell yeah yeah
he said it's a big difference what is
the difference though I mean [ __ ] what's
that okay what's the difference between
having a uh a thousand bucks and a
hundred thousand bucks no a thousand and
ten Grand there's really not a big
difference right if you think about 10
grand and 100 Grand I said that's a good
difference
100 Grand in a million that's the
difference a million and 10 million
that's a big difference yeah 10 million
and 100 massive difference but a hundred
million and a billion sure that's it
that's it I don't think so really so say
you gotta you probably you have a lot of
money right you made you made your 100
million ain't what it used to be though
we all know that but but when you when
you walk around the world and you want
something you don't look at Price tags
you might look at Price tags because
you're used to that but at the end of
the day if you want to go on a vacation
you want to buy car you fly you want to
fly private or what you want to fly very
comfortably
um anybody in your family needs anything
that is money is not an option so you're
you have an equality of consumption that
a billionaire does there comes a point
where how many states can you eat no
question so so in that sense I don't
know your life and you know Rogan was
talking about you which is you know
about you have you have a curiosity
so you've made your money but you like
talking to interesting people and you
like growing and you like thinking and
and figuring out the world and making
sense the world I don't think any of
that would change your biggest you know
so it feels like I don't know that you
where would your life change maybe you'd
fly oh nothing nothing right nothing no
so listen the day the day you know today
I'm having lunch with one of my friends
we were in business we met first time in
sales in 2002. we went to Hawaii on our
first trip and you know we're going to
breakfast at this place in Hawaii in
Kauai and it's 40 bucks a person I'm
like who the hell pays 40 bucks for
breakfast yeah so we went to the local
uh grocery we bought bread turkey and
cheese and my dad and I because I took
my dad to Hawaii so yeah so so that's
that point Robert he's asking me
questions so so how was it the the day
the you know the couple hundred million
hit the account you know what was what
was that that like and I'm like
it was a very good experience yeah okay
when you see that being real because
I've seen 100K hit a million hit 10
million hit 50 hit but I've not had this
this hit
it was great it was awesome but I was
working the same exact schedule the next
day next day same because you still need
meaning in your life you want your
relationships to work all that stuff man
but but the gunpowder you know you know
at a at a time like that it's fun to
play if you're playing the game if
you're doing it for money you will slow
down uh Brian I've seen Allah you said
something very important at the
beginning of the podcast the first five
minutes
you said you know sometimes this happens
to all of us the world economic foreign
people get together and they think
they're smarter than everybody I can
solve everybody's problems and we kind
of forget about the fact that you know
humility and all of them we talk about
meditations right you want to know real
quickly how big somebody thinks let them
win something let them get a big check
let him get a big victory you're going
to learn about them very quickly yeah if
if a person gets a 100 000 auto check uh
uh in sales if somebody who's never made
50k in a month they made 15 a month
you'll learn exactly what happens next
90 days if they slow down it was all
about the money
but if the guy makes 50k for the first
time and he comes to work the next day 7
30 a.m or 8 o'clock it was never about
the money you see a person that you know
has a big hit with a show and let me
tell you one video went viral I know
something to do I've had this one thing
that
another guy's like I don't even know
what you're talking about yeah coming to
doing others because I'm curious I'm
trying to learn this whole concept of
who wins in any game takes a decade two
three four decades but then when you see
the separation we're just 30 years ago
they were at the same level just 20
years ago they were at the same level
you realize who thinks the biggest and
then credit goes to the biggest thinkers
and well that's for sure with stand up
or anything you you money's not gonna
help you get funnier and success sure as
hell isn't if you don't stay hungry you
know one of the things I I love about
Joe is Joe Rogan is I went and saw him
at uh I was in Utah with my parents and
said come down come down to the Forum
you got to see this and I'm like you
know I was 50 minutes away I think I
come down and I'm I'm just standing in
the wings and watching my friend perform
for 14
000 wow okay I was stuck in traffic I
was going the back way and I was still
stuck in traffic and I'm like what's
this traffic oh they were coming to see
my friend okay so his Fame is as big as
it gets but I got to tell you man I got
to tell you what I saw which is probably
going to hit soon
that that special is as good as anything
he was doing that got him to the game
wow and that's called hunger that he's
always stayed hungry he's always stayed
uncomfortable you know Tyson was talking
um these guys are saying you're saying
30 million dollars doesn't make you
happy and he looked at these guys and he
said so he's got these great nuggets he
goes he said God has a way of getting
back at you by giving you everything you
want wow before you can handle it and I
I was like damn so it's it's like it's
the same thing The Wolf of the door is
luxury but struggle but that's why you
know Joe's the goat you know Joe is the
goat of this space period you're like if
you if you're talking
uh what's the debate right now Jon Jones
right the whole conversation he's the
goat and hey you know did you hear what
he said today was very interesting today
he says I believe God put me in this
world to never lose
he says I am destined to never lose he
says I'm a different breed that I'm
never going to lose a fight that's John
by the way that's a pretty heavy quote
that's a heavy quote Yeah if he believes
that's all that matters by the way right
so but serious you got a Jon Jones you
gotta you gotta MJ you got a Brady you
got a Joe Rogan okay he's in that space
on where he's at but Joe this is the
picture by the way I don't know if you
remember that the uh this is from the
90s I just sent it to Rob I'm like the
square jawed kids show them pictures can
you zoom in or no we got to make sure
look at this that's you I remember
exactly where are you guys going we were
coming back from from uh from doing
stand-up are you guys in an Uber in the
90s no no we were in we were in my
friend's car I think we were my friend
Marie msrendino's car wow in fact and he
had just performed I think I'd done a
thing and he had done like 45 minutes
and crushed and uh what year did you
think this was I was probably literally
1997 I don't know when I was no what
what I've known him since no social
media no no no lucky to have have a you
know one of those it looks like you guys
are on your way to a library to read
some books it looks like you guys are
not causing anything
at all I can't see that happening
is that La it's the feeling I was in New
York
City
right there that's right God yeah crazy
I remember that so well I actually
remember that that it's so weird that I
can remember that how far were you into
your career at that point how far was
Rogan into it I was on a show called Mad
TV yeah of course and uh I can't
remember but I and I'd done some stuff
you know but uh Joe was doing Joe was
done with I think he's done with news
radio then he's doing Fear Factor at
that point nope nope he wasn't doing any
of that he was yeah because that because
that was 95 to 97 he was doing stand-up
back then I don't remember was there
anything about Rogan at that point yes
that was like you're gonna be the goat
of the fundamental difference between
Joe and I as this yeah I suffered from
wishful thinking and I suffered from
something I was very positive and I was
not afraid of the world I had an I had
an upbringing that made me safe I never
catastrophized things I was always like
it'll always work out you know I had an
arrogance when I was a young man which
was the idea that I was one of God's
favorites in a way I worked hard I did
all right in my life but I always had
this sort of idea that you know you
don't have to I always wanted to be the
guy I I never I couldn't stand sit in a
bench in anything I had to be you know I
had to be involved I wanted to be the
people I want to be the guy you're
talking about not that I'm in the game
whatever it was but
but
um I was never as honest with myself
I was always honest but not honest the
way he was he was brutally honest with
himself because Joe grew up in a world
where he only had himself to rely on he
grew up in a world that was dangerous
from the age of about nine on it was
only him man
and I didn't grow up that way so Joe is
always afraid of the world Joe was very
aware of how bad it could be it was like
being it was like um somebody comes out
of war and realizes you're having that
you're complaining about those dinner
rolls yeah is that what you're doing
talk to somebody who came from from a
war-torn country and and watch how
grateful they are but also watch how
hard they work man fear and and the idea
that you never want to go back to that
thing over there is a very powerful
motivator so you know and he's the kind
of guy also who had the imagination and
um and to realize what he was able to
become he he felt his own potential and
he and he figured out a long time ago
that if I work harder than somebody else
more importantly if I'm consistent if
I'm really consistent and I'm really
honest with my shortcomings I'll get
ahead and he was never not intense that
way but I would say to it to add to that
the most important thing was probably
his brutal honesty with everyone around
him and himself that guy was NE I
remember I remember when we were we were
doing when I started doing Mad uh
fighter and the kid we start getting
sponsors and sponsors were coming to us
and we had a long conversation about the
importance of only letting people that
sponsor you be the kinds of Brands you
believe in
if you take shortcuts it's going to be a
bad situation Council and we used to
call it we used to call it the pesky
truth we'd call and sometimes we'd we'd
be talking and we'd fudge some data
and I remember this and he'd go he'd
said he said yeah I asked him a question
yeah the answer was no and he goes no
I mean maybe the answer is no you know
we would always you hold each other to
account and and
more than anybody else he was always the
guy who would say to me you're [ __ ]
you're bullshitting yourself you're not
working hard enough whatever it was he
was that friend you know you know what's
the you know what's the
there's different ways you measure
someone's success right okay so we're
talking about Neil deGrasse Tyson he
says the four things on how to measure
whether someone's going to be success
it's what grades in school you know
ambition social how they're good with
people and the last how they bounce back
right okay what else can you hey how you
measure success for somebody who's a
great parent well watch their grandkids
that's how you measure if they were
grandparent great parent or not because
they raised great kids who raise great
kids right uh one of the ways that it's
very very uh it's not talked about
enough you know the saying
um you are the average of the five
people you hang out with or whatever you
know that whole conversation fine we
give that conversation but
but is it really five
or is it really one person in that five
that's holding everybody together
at the highest level of standards and
it's that one flipping annoying guy that
you love sick that's right that one
person it's not five I am convinced it
is not five it's impossible to be fired
right in the group of five there's an
alpha
that Alpha sets the tone and everybody
eventually says he's the alpha whether
we like it or not he's the alpha the
group and in the alpha you try to
[ __ ] the alpha in the office says
yeah you're full of [ __ ] it's not gonna
happen
the alpha you try to convince yeah what
about we do this yeah I don't know about
that it's not going to happen so some
people can't take that so you sit there
and say screw this guy who the hell does
he think he is you filter out no problem
you were never meant to be in that group
because you can't I you think you are
the alpha you're not the alpha you wish
you were the alpha you don't do what the
alpha does to be the alpha Joe's in
Alpha it's very simple Joe's the alpha
when I uh was with Tate I pulled him
aside so listen I I really like your
brother
you know I really like how he is with
you you know Tristan I said but to me he
knows you're the alpha he says you think
so I don't know if you remember this I
said no I think he knows you're the
alpha and he gives you that respect
right even with DJ Khaled and who's the
other guy about Joe where Fat Joe says
khalid's younger than he's my young but
he's the alpha right each group has that
if you can find a friend like Joe but
there are good outfits and they're a bad
Alpha of course they're not there's a
difference the bad Alpha is a bully and
he's not dealing with the truth no he's
not good Alpha keeps everybody they keep
them in line with the truth and it's not
about it's not about them like he
doesn't need the credit like a real
Alpha doesn't need other people to tell
him they were Alpha and hey I constantly
need confirmation you know a bad Alpha
needs constant confirmation a real Alpha
you don't need confidence the literature
backs you up on everything you said
there men men delineate Authority very
quickly and they they had to you know
for Millennia we came I always had this
joke about but it's true with men that
there is there is one when a man meets
another man for the first time there's
only one primary question in the room
and there's protocol hey how you doing
everything but at the end of the day
when a man meets another man when you
strip it all down
when a man looks at another man the only
thing going on in their brains is could
I kill this man that's it if we're in a
room naked who comes out first and
everything's gonna go
be well what because that's how I fight
but listen that's my because it's a free
country man you're a Puritan bro but I
mean that's not fun I'll make that
wrestling
but hunting is the same way we we came
up for most of our history on foot
we didn't domesticate animals we didn't
kill any distance for most of our
history we were on foot in small groups
with sharp sticks you got to be able to
delineate Authority you got to know
who's the fastest runner who can
actually who can actually you know
wrestle that animal if it comes down to
it you know who who can run the longest
you got to know these things we do this
immediately we still have that Hunter
yeah that Hunter warrior in US brother
you are so right because if you look at
the military hierarchical right if you
look at sports teams companies CEOs CFO
CEO boom boom boom all right where men
are designed to be hierarchical it
starts women are women are more designed
to be egalitarian we're all together
we're all together and this is all this
love yeah yeah well I was just at the
SHOT show in Vegas with uh you know what
that is like the military where they
they have all the guns guns and [ __ ] and
I was with two two dudes I've got to
know who are in Dev group who were in
Seal Team Six wow and one of them was in
the like I think it's still teams who I
didn't know how to clandestine unit or
whatever I guess one of them was in that
ice dude I swear to God if you I I was
having breakfast with him and I didn't
know him the other guy I've known for a
while but but I was like talking to him
and he was such a cool guy and I said
what do you do were you in the military
and they all looked at me and go yeah
until about three months ago and he was
you know sealed but but what struck me
was in a million years I never would
have thought of it he was so socially
aware and intelligence intelligent funny
but those guys have to rely on each
other you you don't get into that unit
without having the love from your
brothers you you you it's all about the
guy next to you it's all about the guy
to the to your right and to your left
and so they have a social IQ that's
crazy high and they have sort of
eclectic interests they're they're
really they're listening to you they're
into whatever you want to talk about if
I'm talking about Acoustics when I'm
doing stand-up where I'm talking about
being able to feel a room I can see like
are they mostly white and well wealthy
are they mostly Hispanic I can feel that
I know exactly what's going on I tailor
it they're in they're listening they're
like tell me more they want more they're
asking questions their attention to
detail is ridiculous yeah military but
but what struck me about these guys is
like it's you just don't judge a book by
its cover bro if you think big muscles
and you know square jaws that no no no
no well I mean you say the first thing
men when they see other men they say can
I kick this guy's ass yeah kill him
except if you're a middle eastern yeah
because Middleton said how big you are I
can bomb this place
when I went to Glendale High School we
had a white teacher and but when I say
white teacher someone's like most
teachers are white not in Glendale High
School because Glendale everybody's
Armenian right if you're a wife you're a
minority yeah and the the white teacher
would say why is it that when Armenians
or you know Persians when you guys get
into fights you say you're going to bomb
this place like why do you guys say that
he says because they're like a is that
like a saying is that like a you can't
joke like that you know some kids would
get suspended or they would get in
trouble but if the average guy says that
nobody does anything somebody from Iran
says you have to take it it's a serious
threat yeah
dude it's for sure they're they're
definitely they're definitely cultures
three Middle Easterns right here talk
about bombing the Jews like hey guys
gotta go I'm Irish Italian
wait he just lumped you in now my Steve
Byrne comic got punched in the jaw not
he had his jaw broken by an Armenian guy
when was this he was a cab driver but
the guy was from Armenia bro and they
got in the thing Steve's little Steve's
a great guy but he'd have to tell you
the story but he kind of a hothead and I
guess Steve said something Steve said
can we take our cab and the guy goes
he's trying to finish things yeah yeah
and Steve goes okay well can we do it
now and he goes give me one minute
please
and she was like I forget this guy and I
guess Steve spit but he didn't mean to
spit at the guy but he kind of hit his
hit the guy's car oh God like or the guy
thought he did dude but Steve wouldn't
do that Steve was just you know yeah I'm
probably telling I'm probably Stephen
probably telling the story completely
wrong but I so they have words but what
Steve didn't understand is this guy's
from Armenia he's not gonna [ __ ] talk
to you bro the guy the guy went
just just kind of squashed this figure
out like like a harbinger of what's
gonna happen to you and just gonna get
that and just hit him like he's
obviously a boxer boom oh he gave his
little two-piece right there he had to
have it he had to have his brother no
yeah dude broke his jaw [ __ ] around a
little two-piece don't [ __ ] around
there's some cultures that are going to
punched in other words if the Uber has
an i-a-n or y-a-n name thank you if he's
French and he's like now
hold on and my the biggest don't [ __ ]
with anybody that smokes a cigarette or
they're covering their mouth like that
that's my face
Telltale sign it's a sign right you know
if he was like this he's like you know I
don't want to fight that's how Sammy the
bull did when but by the way thank you
for hooking me up we spent two days
together brother oh really saw a bunch
of stuff you guys did two days together
took him to dinner did a whole thing
with him was it what you expected 100
and more yeah but the stories endless
dude when you're sitting there with him
and he's got this he's outside he's
smoking hey I never thought in a million
years I'd be out here in the beach and
you know I just want to thank you you
know you brought me in with your family
holy [ __ ] but it was just like I
couldn't I mean this is the most feared
guy ever ever and that's it oh my God I
knew you I picked him up I was nervous
dude I picked them up at the at the
airport he's in a T-shirt and uh and I'm
like hey but he's got a sense of humor
about it very funny
it's a very funny we bring him he's he's
in the studio of the fighter in the Kids
Studio
and uh you know Brennan the sixth I was
just going to say right so he's look
right here here oh I shot I'm nervous
hell yeah look at him
I'm talking see how much I'm talking way
too much I don't know what's gonna
happen with his eyes what's in the bag
what's in the bag so so Brendan is there
and then there's Mark Harley who's a
huge big bodybuilder big guy both 240
270. and and Sammy's looking at these
guys and uh he made some hey how you
doing yeah how you doing like that and
then there's a pause and they're just
standing there and he goes
now I'm going to arrest you both at the
same time
he's just got he's great do you remember
he said yeah I do that's why I was like
you know yeah you can say that and you
got to say that when you know when
you're when you're with them yeah uh but
maybe he did I don't I don't know if he
did or not but oh the shot was like you
know there's different types of tough
right no but but uh but it's fine but uh
mind you piece yeah and be respectful
that's what I'm trying to tell because
this is me now Sammy I want to apologize
to the account of my friends
yeah we're gonna say but you you're
about to say something about him so so
one day Sammy comes to our house this is
like a few months ago he comes to the
house he's going on talking to the kids
you know Dylan's talking to him so that
he's like so what's his name is Sammy
the bull I'm Sammy the bull so Dylan's
like enamored by his name what a great
name Samuel fantastic so he goes to
school the teacher asks him so he said
so how was your day says well Daddy's
friend showed to our house I met a Sammy
the bull oh and he's just like who did
you meet yes this is a Christian School
oh my God so I get a phone call you know
you're sunk enough say that Sammy the
bull was at your house I said what do
you mean he can't say that well he can't
say that because he wasn't I said no he
was at the house oh my God which sent me
the ball I said the same one you're how
many centimeters
can I ask I said yeah he's a he's a he
was he came he's a person that we have
done a lot of collaborations together
with oh I'm so sorry I thought Dylan
just was I said no he's telling the
truth the teacher and then after this
moment the next day the teacher's like
Hey where's your homework and the kid is
like none of your [ __ ]
Dylan finds out yeah
it's like my son my son 11 years old I
got something I Go why'd you lie I
caught him this actually when he was 10.
I caught him red-handed why'd you lies
hey I want an answer why'd you lies
I go look at me right now why did you
lie he goes it's in my nature okay
you taught me well then he didn't say
that he did he didn't he did that my son
my son I gotta tell you he's gonna be a
comic this kid this kid thinks outside
the box yeah
do you laugh oh dude he kills me
you have no idea those moments where Jen
and I look at each other and we're both
trying to prevent from laughing because
it's a serious moment but you can't do
it dying I'm like I walk away I
literally I'm not gonna hang on I'll be
back cause I'm pissed right away you
know what I said I'll kick your ass
I will kick your ass mother he got me he
got me that must be hard because think
about it that moment is a very like
because and being I remember those
moments as a kid if they break if they
laugh then I'm like they're not taking
it that seriously no but it is serious
well you know what Senna can do Senna
can go from crying to stopping to
laughing
she's an actor or in like Jesus Oh bro
she's hilarious Gemini she's hilarious
by the way let's talk about another
genius how about Stephen Crowder you
guys hear about what happened with
Stephen Crowder I I know a little
Steven's a friend of mine's yeah but I
don't know I I don't know anything I
just saw the daily wire gave a response
but it was too long to listen to It's
like an hour yeah do you have a story on
it or do you want me to just kind of say
a couple things on so he here's here's
what we do now okay Crowder does a video
for those of you that don't know who
Crowder is he's got six million
subscribers a comedian conservative I
mean the guy's a rock star funny comics
he should oh you should be doing it he's
he's yeah on top of billions of views
and he does his 27 minute clip 28 minute
clip and when you're watching it you
don't really know who he's talking about
but he's upset about a contract and
everybody's like well is he talking
about these guys is he talking about
those guys he's with the blaze is it the
blaze I said this is it that and then
eventually you know within a few hours
the CEO of uh daily wire does a one hour
video responding to it explaining that
he was talking about them because the
entire Market was talking about this my
phone kept blowing up people saying did
you see this did you see I'm like what
tell me what's going on here and then uh
anyways so apparently these guys were
offering him 50 million dollars
for four years is what the contract was
and uh all in they're going to end up
investing around 100 million dollars
into Crowder but it would be him having
to move everything with them
responsibilities of 190 something
episodes per year if you miss one it's
this much if you get a strike it's this
much all these different things that's
in there which you know one side is like
well that as a business owner you have
to have that the talent is like well you
know I think I'm worth more you should
pay me this you should pay me that but
it all got public and there's a lot of
different uh
you know some are saying why did he do
it public it should have been private
some are saying good that he did it
there's so many people in the talent
space that you know want to uh uh have
this be known because sometimes Talent
gets stuck like you know back in the
days rappers or singers that would get a
Contracting and boom they're like you
own this you own that and it was you
know a lot of people got Sony had an
issue with that when they Michael
Jackson one time got up and called that
you know Tommy McCullough I don't know
if you remember that or not oh yeah
there's a bunch of this in that space so
uh uh we're gonna see what happens next
with this but these are you know these
are two big names you're talking about
who's the underpal is he with is he's
with the blaze he's with the blaze okay
but he's got independent and he's got
stuff that he does with the blaze is it
possible though that this contract was
the first draft that their lawyers
gave him you know what I'm saying
sometimes you'll in negotiations lawyers
come at you with a terrible deal and
then you go get serious and you send it
back so I wonder is this was this the
first iteration did they even see it
when they sent it you know you know uh
uh so when when the when the company
that made an offer to uh by us I'll
never forget what he told me best thing
he told me when him and I were talking
he has done a couple hundred deals okay
this guy's name is Brian Adams he's a
he's the biggest heavyweight in
insurance right now you build a company
10 billion dollar companies what he's
done he's done very well for himself
and he says look here's here's one thing
that you have to keep in mind
if this deal doesn't happen it won't be
because you and I don't want to be in
business together it's because lawyers
screwed it up okay he says every time
our lawyers get to a point where the
deal is not going to work out you and I
have to get on the phone together that's
right okay it was the best Council by
the way on what he gave
so
two weeks into it our side of the lawyer
the one we had from New York
one of the most feared lawyers in all of
America and I'm not being like I've
dealt with so many lawyers over the last
20 years we've spent
I don't know 12 million dollars on legal
fees 11 million dollars in legal fees so
when you're dealing with lawyers lawyers
come in many different shapes and forms
he's the same ebull of lawyers this guy
is the most feared lawyer ever wow
so there is no how's your day going
there is no how's your day going okay
I'm here to do the job here's what I'm
doing and he goes at their throat holy
[ __ ] this is the shittiest contract I've
seen in my life you're trying to take
advantage of this what kind of a bunch
of this is this you guys are corrupt you
guys are this and he's gone so so they
call me you know your lawyer just told
our 13 lawyers this did you know this
so let me give them a call so I call him
up so our board we talk to each other
and I give this guy a call I say man
listen
I love the fact that you're a pit bull
you're our pit bull but maybe try to be
a German Shepherd for a minute instead
of a pit bull you're a little bit like
you know yeah you say well listen this
is what you pay me to do this is how I
do business this is why I'm the best in
the marketplace and I'm going to stick
to what I'm doing wow I said I totally
get it go from a 9.9 to try to get to an
8.8 if you can right
so he's good for two weeks every two
weeks
by the way this one for six months every
four weeks we had to have a call like
this do you know how many times a deal
almost fell through if I told you nine
times that's a small number okay yeah
it's not worth it to me it was so many
times that the deal almost fell through
so for here there needs to be listen bro
our lawyers work for us your lawyers
work for you yeah they're going to write
up a contract that benefits us and your
guys are going to fight for what's
benefits you and we're really dealing
with 20 different things here okay under
20 different things you can't tell me
all 20 things are important to you
neither can I tell you 20 things are all
important to me I have to tell you what
are my five most most important you tell
me what are your five most important and
let's negotiate the bottom the middle
ten is that fair yes I don't know if
that was that took place here because
once the deal happens you got to get the
lawyers to talk if you guys negotiate
money it's a problem
and again I don't I know nothing about
it I don't have a relationship with
Crowder your friends I him and I have
never spoken to each other he's going to
be on the podcast here so good yeah he's
going to be on the podcast here next
couple days is he he's coming in he's
coming in yeah so I don't I don't have a
we're working on everything up in the
area I don't know if you don't know he's
not coming for stand-up they reached out
and he's getting we've been going back
and forth but seashells with Benny yeah
we have something set up for next week
which we'll be announcing here shortly
uh so so and then I don't have a
relationship with the folks at Daily
wire at all so it's not like hey I'm
friends with these guys we had a
conversation I've never spoken to the
CEO of daily wire we've never broken
bread we've never exchanged email
nothing uh but normally when you see
deals like this
the job of daily wire is to write a
contract that benefits them and the job
of you know Crowder as a big face of
getting the type of eyeballs that he's
getting is to protect him let the
lawyers do the Dirty Work once you get
involved it's messy yeah I agree it's
messy it's going to be uh and by the way
Jordan Peterson apparently tweeted
something and then he took it off oh
really yeah
daughters podcast Michaela yeah yeah um
Saturday I've never met her but how does
it get to this point like we're in an
eyeball attention economy yeah this is
pure speculation is any of this for
views about none of that no this is just
what business gone ugly and they should
have kept it under wraps like how does
this get to the pop culture status
unless at least if your card unless if
your name is last name is Kardashian
where your business model is for your
personal life to be public yeah
everywhere you don't want your personal
life to be public okay you keep it to
yourself This is not stuff that you want
to be public you just don't want to be
public and it's public that yeah I would
I would agree with that I don't know
I'm good I can't believe is Jordan
Peterson still in this whole mess with
the People's Republic of Canada yeah
Justin Trudeau do you have any thoughts
on that or yeah yeah of course I mean I
I'm
I just think it's a classic example of
what happens when government gets too
powerful and you have an ideology that
believes that they can engineer equality
and which really means the only way to
do that is by force I mean that's what
happens if you're gonna if you're going
to enforce your your what you believe to
be true because you figured it out for
all of us because you figured out the
gender thing that the rest of us been
living our lives but you figured that
out apparently your experts have all the
answers your experts have all the
answers on global warming we're going to
die at any minute and all this stuff and
all of this is settled science by the
way and all this is not for debate we'll
just stop that I can always tell when
people don't really have good ideas when
they refuse to debate or they try to
silence you that's always a good
indication when they're afraid to
actually open themselves up and maybe
realize that their ideas aren't fully
formed maybe there's a better idea out
there and all that but that you know
Justin Trudeau is not yeah interested
what is actually happening with he's
being he's being asked to take
social media
um re-education programs of sorts no he
apparently the the board of
psychiatrists in in the gutless board of
psychiatrists in Canada is basically
being told that he basically said you
will lose your license if you don't take
our course and you have to pay for it
and then we'll tell you when we think
you're better it's an outrage
one completely submitted a full
transcript of Peterson's four-hour
interview with Rogan last year claiming
that a statement's on faulty climate
change models and the dangers of
promoting radical gender Theory violated
the professional code of conduct for
psychologists accredited with the ocp
Peterson stands accused of undermining
his profession by speaking on areas well
outside his area of competence and make
him problematic unethical and
professional unprofessional comments
it's amazing yeah he's got to take a
remedial course on social media
Communications with a board-issued
therapist it's like a I mean it sounds
like a joke
but this is what happened in all these
socialist Utopias this was what happened
during the Communist Revolutions in all
the countries whether it was Yugoslavia
whether it was
um you know Hungary whether it was the
Soviet Union of course this is the kind
of [ __ ] you live in anything with
re-education you're saying this doesn't
happen in America
I'm saying this could happen in America
very easily right now you don't think
it's happening like you know how some of
these guys are like well you listen you
know I I was asked to take a six-week
class on being a nympho and I'm fully
ready now to make my marriage work hey
you're required to take a six-week
course why it's not good to uh uh you
know do this or it's less I'm less
concerned with animals or doing that or
well I'm less concerned with whatever
that is I'm more concerned with how what
they're doing in our schools you see so
so when certain things like gender
Theory become settled science and now
you want to teach uh kindergarteners to
third grade about sexual orientation and
gender
before they even have a context for what
the world is about and someone like to
Santa says this is this is not going to
fly let kids be kids and figure some
other things out first please and let
parents deal with that maybe and they
they call it a don't say Gator yeah and
call it a an appalling anti-trans Bill
Etc that narrative just doesn't fly dude
you you didn't think about this stuff
until about 20 minutes ago anyway so
these are the kinds of ideas that are
bad ideas that have to be pushed back by
the way what's crazy is it's going to be
you know we learned one thing just two
months ago okay whatever the policies
descent has pushed or people in Florida
liked and he went from winning by 34 000
votes to one and a half million vote
democracy okay yeah so the exactly one
of them is whether it's parents whether
it's you know leave a vaccine out
whether it's education whether it's all
of that stuff that he went through okay
the way of handling of you decide what
you want to do with your body the man
all these things right okay
did you hear what Trump said today about
uh vaccine and how that came out did you
hear it no so Trump made comments a
Newsweek story I think that's the one
right there yeah so he he says Donald
Trump supporters turned on him over a
vaccine defense sold out so hard so go
up a little bit go up a little bit go up
a little bit where he says uh uh during
a recent appearance on a conservative
podcast water cooler Trump appraises
Administration for operation reps warp
speed rollout of the vaccine and for
helping save tens of millions lives
Trump refused to get drawn when host
David Brody pushed a suggestion that the
vaccines were not as safe or effective
as medical experts you have to
understand there are pros and cons some
Reports say that it's the greatest thing
ever happened
and we saved tens of millions of lives
then you'll read other reports that say
there were some problems with the
vaccine but relatively small numbers
Trump said yeah well when you think of
the overall number yeah of course so but
here's the question though here's a
question but you know you have many
reports that the vaccine safety millions
of lives Trump added without that
without the vaccines you would have had
a thing where perhaps a hundred million
people would have died okay that's a
trumpism before before I before I give
you my thoughts on this yeah do you guys
have any thoughts because I got some
thoughts on this what do you think on
just his what he said yeah so so so
nothing surprises me about Trump he's a
guy he'll say nobody loves the Bible
more than me you know he just says these
things you know nobody loves Muslims
more than I do so he he has this
tendency to what's it called exaggerate
but I mean it's unbelievable the guys
are unbelievable it's in nature right
but for me
I can't stop watching him yeah he's
either my drunk uncle or my 10 year old
son I can't stop watching him because he
cracks me up with that because he's just
got the the gall to do that and I think
he's aware of that but for me I think a
lot of the stuff like I just listened to
Brett Weinstein evolutionary biologists
I'm Rogan I don't I'm not I'm not an
immunologist by the way yeah yeah I'm
not an immunologist vaccinologist I
don't know anything but when you hear
people who are not only biologists
talking to top tier scientists in that
space and they're casting doubts but I
always say that we didn't know a lot at
the time a lot of mistakes were made
there was desperation there was panic
I I was always against the blanket
shutdowns it made no sense to me I was
always I always had a problem with the
idea that masks were gonna it didn't
make sense I was flying too much and you
take them off then you put them on there
I just didn't buy it so I'm very weary
of all that that you know government
bureaucracy that's my thought you know
you know you got thoughts on this before
I give you mine go for it let me tell
you what I think he's doing okay so do
you guys remember when he first said the
warp speed vaccine's going to be ready
in nine months of course do you remember
what Biden Kamala Harris and everybody
on the left said I wouldn't put that in
my body okay so so let me tell you what
he's he's doing people think
people think this guy is like a
uh uh uh you know lightweight just you
know emotion all this other stuff he is
making the left okay
imagine if it gets to a point where the
left now starts saying we have to
investigate The credibility of vaccine
whether it was the right move to do or
not and it was all Trump's fault okay I
don't know if you're on somewhere I'm
going with this so he he may be
cornering them to have to come out and
say well you know some of the studies
shows maybe this is not good for you in
heart attack and all this other stuff
he's a political animal you don't know
what I'm saying sir he's a gangster this
guy is just maybe toying with them to
get CNN to respond to get that clip and
say boom motive I'm gonna run with that
for the next six to 12 months and tell
you you just messed up okay what you
said was the best thing I came up with
so either except the fact that it was
done in nine months because of me or or
realize that it's not good for everybody
it's on you so what do you want to do
here
so it's a double-edged sword game he's
playing with everybody and and again I'm
thinking that's the strategy is made
what you're saying he's so crazy but
crazy like a fox yeah he's very good at
knowing what people respond to I
probably told the story but I remember
my buddy said I knew he's going to win
when when they were talking about Romney
and they go now do you think that Romney
uh his the do you think the fact that
Romney is so rich is a liability for him
politically and Trump goes he's not rich
I'm rich
you're not gonna win now
and then the best was when Bloomberg was
running too short
now I don't know if you saw what he said
it was the greatest thing I've ever seen
it was amazing you know that Bloomberg
never say he goes you know the problem
was I like Mike I like Mike but he wants
a stool
that's what he's saying he goes he wants
a store you know save you sure be sure
why do you need a stool you want to be
eye level with me you got a store I got
a stool you know he didn't ask for a
stool
I'm voting for you I don't even like you
I vote for you on that I can't I can't
deny you on that that'd be amazing if
Bloomberg didn't even ask for the school
by the way people are saying by the way
the rumor has it that he never asked for
himself no that's what I'm saying you
didn't that was Trump dude he that's a
New York thing that's a New York that's
when you play Touch football with your
friends you should have seen what I
would play I was I had no business be on
the field they were all way better we've
been playing touch football with these
the other teams the insults the New York
insults where the guy would be like do
something and my buddy Jimmy would be
like you know she's all mad at me now
because you guys are writing us she's
mad at me because I was bumping her ref
I mean it's ridiculous stop calling me
she goes now now her tits are getting
off and we just get killed down and
double down go dude get your highlights
are coming out they're just you know
you're always he comes from that but
he's a master attitude he'll find out
where you're weak you know some people
there's nothing you get if you've grown
up certain way you you know immediately
where somebody what somebody's ashamed
of somebody's proud that dude can find
out he can find where you have a window
open in your house and he'll climb into
that window by the way you know who else
has that Jake Paul has that as well yeah
oh really Jake Paul has that as well
it's a very unique gift not everybody
has that well Donald Trump by the way
Connor I'm willing to say but he's not
at Jake's level you mean boxing wise or
uh Condors are better trolling wise no
trolling wise he's not a Jake's level
Connor is an Entertainer [ __ ] talker
yeah like you can listen to the way he
was talking [ __ ] to Mayweather because
he was entertaining of course but Jake
Paul talks [ __ ] and gets under your skin
it's a very different skill set Jake's
more Trump a Connor is more
um
you know Connor is more some of the uh
like Michael Jordan's way of talking
[ __ ] he got under your skin 100 he
played mental games with you he did all
Gary Payton was also on a similar level
some of these guys Muhammad when you
hear stories Ali he did that Sonny
Liston you know Sonny Liston was the
most feared fighter in the world so I
listened everybody was terrified of
nobody hit harder than Sonny Liston and
Ali knew that Sonny had been in jail and
David ramnick wrote this book about the
Scrapbook and and Ali knew that the one
thing that Sunny was afraid of was crazy
so Ali literally was behaved in a crazy
way he he rented a bus had a megaphone
and in the middle of the night was
Sonny's sleeping with his wife and he
hears you you can't you got nothing on
me you got and he comes out like in his
windows what the [ __ ] is going on you
[ __ ] guys the guy's [ __ ] literally
went at the weigh-in Sunny was it was
trying to get away from him because he
was afraid Ali was going to bite him so
I don't want that guy to bite me he
might be crazy so by the time he got in
the ring he goes this guy's out of his
[ __ ] mind this young kid is out of
his mind like he's not stable and then
he didn't but by the way I'm convinced
and I know you know everybody is there's
a lot of people that have uh um that
maybe voted for Trump that they have
been persuaded to count them out a lot
of people have counted them out this is
not about you like them you know you
want him this is not about that this is
about
understanding and uh respecting the
opponent right the the possibility of
what this guy could do I'm convinced
they are doing whatever they can for
this guy not to run because they know
there's only one person that knows how
to get under everybody's skin on the
right and it's only him it's not the
scientist they know the sentence is a
safe CEO that's who he is he's a CEO
that'll get the job done he's a seal
that'll come and he worked his way up
from Congress to Governor to president
so he knows that you have to go figure
out a way to broker deals and all that
other stuff at least he knows our world
it's going to be a little bit easier to
deal with a DeSantis then it's going to
be to deal with who Trump's never gone
to Congress DeSantis was in the military
military there's a lot of politics
Congress there's a lot of politics
Governor there's a lot of politics and
in president there's going to be a lot
of politics
both sides
politicians the career politicians both
sides
99 of everybody from both sides wants if
there's a republican they want the
sentence of course they don't want Trump
problems people don't vote in primaries
yeah that's the other problem exactly so
so it's jazzed up people do huh yeah it
was jazzed up fanatical those are the
Trump people those are the exactly so
you saw what Mickey Kelly said a couple
months ago making kills like there's no
way in the world the sentence beats
Trump no way zero chance definitely not
in the Prime Minister makes it zero
chance DeSantis beats Trump in the
primary zero chance because the the the
the most die-hard Republicans vote in
primaries the rest of us are like ah you
know I don't know but but um I think
you're right the question is does he
have more than 30 of the population
right this trumpet Trump he's got 30 we
know that but his the candidates he
endorsed and you know yeah no I think
all of them lost except for one right so
in that sense it was kind of like is the
shine wearing off what's going on you
know what they they finding the
Republicans are finding people don't
like this election deny us denial stuff
they don't like it when when when you
start talking about election denial
people go wait a minute those people are
crazy like voters like a lot of the
Republican voters and the independence
which is really what we're talking about
that they kind of go I don't want to be
around we talked about this the other
day so I want to ask you to see to see
what you would say with this
labels carry a lot of weight okay and
some know how to be like Teflon or you
know just like a duck hey Waters off my
back nothing's gonna happen to me what
label do you think carries the most
weight right now because what you just
said right now is one of the labels
right which is what
that candidate is a election election
denial that candidate is an anti-vac
that candidate is a you know that
candidate is racist that candidate is a
bigger that candidate is this what label
do you think carries the most weight
right now to hurt you in in
yet of course to hurt you what what
label carries the most weight right now
to hurt you a candidate or even anybody
this is I mean I think for both sides
wouldn't be different for a Democrat
because they're not really I think I
think abortion is a very big issue for a
lot of people anti-abortion and anti
well I I I just think that that Roe v
Wade timing was not good for the
Republicans a lot of people were just
like dude this has been president for 50
years and you heard a story about that
on why that was done the way it was done
no so some say McConnell pushed it to be
done before midterms
because he wanted that for the Dems
because he knew how much would matter to
them 68 69 the nation whatever the
numbers that's four yeah Choice he knew
that was only going to hurt one person
it wasn't it was going to hurt Trump so
he knew that now that is a conspiracy I
didn't tell you that's a factor some
people are saying that you could have
waited until midterms to do so imagine
if they do that in January or February
or March why would you wait to do right
so they forced it for it to be done
nobody had to force it to be done before
so yeah
exactly so read the room you know but it
was a way to show hey these people that
Trump's endorsing guys knock it off yeah
that's a good question what label is the
biggest liability you're saying for
Republicans I'm saying well I mean
Republicans don't put a lot of labels on
the left what what label do Republicans
put on the left
only one but by the way I'm being
serious critical right theorists give me
multiple labels Republicans put on thems
put on them not not
because they keep doing it over and over
and over again right so it's a two-part
question one is which label carries the
most weight number two how do you combat
against a label what is the right
solution but let's not go to the second
part here what's the heaviest I think
politically it's it's if you look at the
midterm elections it would be election
denial that you know if you're an
election denier that that's that was a
problem apparently if you listen to
people I would say race it once somebody
called you a racist that's it bro like
even like Trump with the whole Mexico
the Border where he's like you know some
of the people coming over you know some
of them are killers and somebody goes
he's racist bro hold on and I'm just
saying the thing that's played out
though I don't think I don't know people
kind of go geez I think racist is very
uh 1980s 1990s I think at the top of the
list we talk about election deniers
racist uh misogynist sexist I think
um white supremacist is top of the list
because under white supremacists you get
anti-semitic you get racist you get
prejudiced yeah well white supremacy
still to this day it's like yeah that's
not the one you want to be known as and
from my experience but just from La
before not before I moved here but for
the whole time during Trump and every
person they put a microphone in front of
that was a minority it was like what do
you think about Trump oh he's like he's
a racist no matter who it was that label
carried the most by the way if you're a
pro if you're a pro if you're pro-life
it's a that is for a lot of people if
you if you walk around L.A or certain
parts and say you're pro-life or you're
voting for a pro-life candidate it's an
act of War so that that's I would say
probably the biggest liability okay so
let's go back
let's go back to it so election deny a
racist bigot anti-vaxx or misogynist
white supremacist Q Anon which one's at
the top
I still think racist I think race is the
question what do you think Rob election
denial might be careful
yeah I think so because right now if you
go anti-vaccine there's enough evidence
where you have doubts but there's not
enough evidence that's been presented to
sway people who are election tonight
could it be Qing
Q Anon carries a lot of weight if they
say he's a q a she's a q a the way I'm
doing this just so you know is math so
you might have 30 of the country who's
like I'm behind you anti-vaxxer or uh
you might have yeah uh Q Anon you might
have 10 of the country zero percent of
the country is trying to be affiliated
with white supremacy right and if you
are let's pay let's pick the top three
so let's just say you're saying election
denier white supremacists let's say Q
Anon racist anti-vaxxer okay fine no
problem how do you fight against these
labels
what is the right strategy to fight
against labels because you have to know
as you get louder
and you make more notes what labels has
Rogen gotten what lately okay what else
has he got right right wing podcast
right it's unbelievable what else has he
got these are labels about right faster
right rethinker is now a bad thing I
don't think free thinker is yet well
they tried the racist thing off yeah
show races
like right winger that's almost like a
that's you know you don't you could you
just label that whole God how about this
so anti-establishment
okay so which one has stuck would Rogan
none none of it so how do you fight when
right winger thing I was gonna say when
you're an election denier that you
double those people double down on that
if you're pro-life that's a religious
stance usually if you're uh you know so
so I don't see anybody fighting that I
think that you are labeled that because
that is what you are and that's part of
your political platform and that's that
comes with negative but also positive
results if you're Republican you are
going to be pro-life if you're a
republican you're going to be you know X
Y and Z uh if you are a Democrat a lot
of times we know that how you feel about
the biggest issue is that we know a lot
of people in the leaders of
quote-unquote thought or at least
pundits I can usually finish their
sentences I know where you stand on most
things give me one issue you tell me
your your uh climate your you think that
the globe is warming and that we have to
and human beings have done it all I can
probably tell you where you stand on a
lot of other stuff that's a bummer but
it's true right so if if you got all the
vaccines in the booster I can it's a
personality trait I can usually tell
that that is your see I believe that you
don't choose to be a Republican or a
Democrat a liberal or conservative I
think it chooses you
I think you have a series of personality
traits and Jonathan Heights done great
work on this in the righteous mind but
there's the the I think that there's no
question that's and and what's his name
Jordan Peterson talks about this too you
know you there are certain
characteristics to your personality that
will cause you to lean left or cause you
to lean right and you can't you can try
to fight that then you have your
experience you're saying it's the nature
versus nurture debate and it's in your
nature if I don't pee now I'm gonna die
[Laughter]
it hurts let me try to help you with
your other way question for you guys
when he comes back so Beyonce uh uh
Beyonce gets paid
24 million dollars to perform one hour
in Dubai who and who who's paying who's
doing it I have no idea what it is it's
probably a royal family I mean 24
million bucks for one one hour so here's
a question yeah is it overpaid or
underpaid over one 100 but what is it if
it's is it in Saudi Arabia dude hold on
she's probably gonna overpaid 100 is she
going down is that the most anybody's
going to pay anybody anything in the
world yeah 24 1 000 it's overpaid unless
she's throwing gold at people by the way
okay so Adam overpaid or under 24
million controversial I actually think
she's one of the most overrated
musicians there is I constantly ask
people who do you like better Rihanna or
Beyonce because Rihanna makes hits Bang
Yeah but Beyonce has this what is it the
B the honey the B's Squad whatever the
beehives yeah I don't I don't know if
it's like the Destiny's Child the the
Jay-Z the Mystique sounds that good yeah
play the Play-Doh you know what I kind
of agree this is her right now
she's testing the sound that's the hotel
that's being done at her performance
24 million dollars for an hour okay so
overpaid underpaid I'm gonna say it's
underpaid
24 million for an hour yeah so first of
all let's give us the math let's do the
math so you're not paying 24 Like A guy
offered me to speak at an event uh
International right now I get paid 250
an hour to speak okay 250 000 someone oh
my God 250 000 and we turned it down not
because I'm worried about going to Iraq
but we just turned it down okay we
turned down 90 of speaking opportunities
in the states 200 000 and they say how
is your rate 200 000 an hour because
it's not an hour yeah you want me to go
to La I'm losing a full day you want me
to go there no it's 200 000 for a day
and a half I'm not doing this for 12 so
really two hundred thousand dollars I'm
in Wi-Fi which is Wi-Fi typically
doesn't work when you're 30 000 you know
feed in the air you get you can't get
the job done and so it ends up being 200
000 for a day divided by 12 hours it's
really only sixteen thousand dollars an
hour I can do a lot more than sixteen
thousand dollars an hour so Beyonce is
getting paid 24 million dollars for now
hour for one hour first of all the
private jet to go to Dubai and come back
you know how much that is that's a
that's a million and a half holy [ __ ]
you mean two million dollar fee to go
from Oh you mean because she has to pay
it I mean uh in gas and stuff yeah if
you go with if you go with a G6 fit
whatever you do you're spending a
million dollars to go to the of course
a million dollars for Christmas we went
from here to Aspen and back that's 150
000 wow if you're going from here to
Dubai 20 hours Aspen is four hours so
four yeah it's a six hundred thousand
dollar bill and Patrick is what you're
spending well it's a million dollar bill
and imagine what jet they're sending so
then who's going with her no the exactly
I've been spending two million dollars
this is such [ __ ]
man I always get screwed so meaning that
and then she has to go a day in advance
to prep she's there for probably three
or four days it's really not 24 million
dollars an hour it's 24 million dollars
divided by 36 hour hours she's really
only getting paid eight hundred thousand
dollars an hour yeah that's [ __ ]
yeah that's by the way if I was her
agent that's how I would sell it that's
incredible
you're talking about his opportunity
cost it's not just the one out I'm gonna
say first of all that's a lot if I'm
telling you I'm telling you you want me
to bring my talent everybody wants for
she does five million in Vegas it's a
one hour flight okay five million right
now if you want Beyonce to go to perform
in Vegas if she's available it's 5
million for an hour but it's a one hour
flight wow to go to Dubai 24 million I
think it was a low uh they lowball they
got I think Dubai one amazing well
what's the famous story it could have
been a plumber could have been lawyer
whoever it is they're like oh we have a
problem get him in here and he comes in
and he fixes the problem in five minutes
he's like yeah there'll be a thousand
bucks he's like you charge a thousand
bucks in five minutes it's like you're
not paying me for the five minutes
you're paying me for the 30 years of
experience that to know what the hell's
going on here because I can fix it is
that what it is because he drew a thing
and the woman said can I have that he
goes twenty four thousand dollars she's
like but you just you know he goes if
you did that in two seconds he goes yeah
I know but it took me 40 years
yeah
with a plumber I don't know if it's true
but that would be the well I'm just
curious I mean it's not that much
curiosity but Dubai has how many billion
of the money in Dubai is well are they
going to sell tickets to our performance
oh yes and then they'll make their money
back oh yeah it's like this I can't you
know I do I do this podcast For What 100
Grand and that's yeah and that's but
that's my give to you and that's that's
because I love you thank you the whole
time the whole time because when they
offered you five you're like no no I
like him I don't even have a changing
room this is yeah that's crazy it's
[ __ ] up but yeah man that's what
you've done my friend you got into
podcasting yeah you just what do you
think about this crazy podcast you're
killing it though yeah I mean I watch
you you're all you're all over the place
but you're you you're engaging in
important discussion and you're moving
the needle in the right direction and
you listen so well and it's just you
know I don't know you've stayed so
grounded you know you might fly private
but you're hungry you're still hungry
and I told you your tummy's a little
tight um
good he's good he's got tight tight
belly and heavy arms well you know I
appreciate that but uh there's a part of
it that if it's if it's uh if you really
enjoy it and you're having fun with it
and then you're like this becomes a game
and then you ask the question what are
the possibilities and you know you're
meeting all sorts of interesting for me
when I was in the Army you know one of
the things I loved about the Army you
were in the Air Force so you kind of
have an idea what happens like for me I
look forward to the weekends because we
would be up till four o'clock in the
morning shooting the [ __ ] playing cards
talking darts pool Billiards and we're
just having great conversations man
great conversations who's the greatest
coach of all time who is the greatest
general of all time who was the best
this who was the what do you think what
about that what about this and some of
the best podcasts that I've ever been a
part of were in the army that were never
recorded wow that's great and if they
were recorded today it would be multiple
strikes on YouTube by the way dude you
know you know what I'm doing it's so
funny you do you know what I'm doing I'm
doing a thing so I've got my podcast but
I'm doing a thing now where I have two
GoPros in my car
and I record the phone calls I have with
my father and my best friends who are
the most thoughtful people in my life
awesome and I'm going to put that on
patreon I'm going to call it cruising
with Callan and I just came up with this
idea because I had these conversations
that my some of my friends are so
brilliant and nobody hears these
conversations and I'm learning as I'm
talking to them and why not I'm driving
to another podcast why not just record
this is like part of my life and you
know so I'll have these conversations
with my father was 82 years old and I'm
learning things and I'm like I I want to
put this out there why not do you know
do you know what we don't know which is
like the the craziest thing uh uh I'm
gonna ask you a question and you give me
the dollar amount what it's worth okay
okay let's play this game what is a 1952
Mickey Mantle tops PSA 10 rookie card
worth to you for me nothing okay for you
that's the point but that's that's the
answer so the answer is what it's worth
to you yes okay what is a uh a Ferrari
La Ferrari 2014 worth to you yeah I'm
not a car guy okay perfect so what is a
uh uh two uh uh be in a movie uh a
Scorsese movie with Joe Pesci Pacino and
DeNiro what is award to you would you
pay to be in that movie lifetime goal
what would you pay to be in that movie
whatever I got it for a lot but but look
what happened to you whenever you'd pan
a Ferrari whatever you pay for Ferrari
you would want to be in a movie with and
you got a key role peshi De Niro and
Pacino right okay so to somebody else I
don't want to be in a movie I just want
to watch it you guys do it I'll go and
watch it I'm not going to be okay what
is it worth to you to travel to Monaco
and have dinner at Le Louis with every
living president what does it work to
you it's interesting five hours what is
a word to you a lot what would you pay
for it I'm being serious what would you
pay would you pay a million bucks to go
to something like that I had it yeah if
you had it you would it would be worth
going through dinner like that right 100
you ready for the last question I love
the tricky one bro it's an emotional one
you ready yeah what is it worth to you
to have 2 000 hours of footage of
conversations of your father grandfather
grandmother what is the word to you a
lot
think about that
what would you do today you know what I
would be doing today
I'd be sitting there glued to the screen
going through 2 000 hours of content
documenting to see what my grandpa was
thinking in 1924 and 1941 and 1930 this
that's all you'd be thinking about what
you and I don't know bro is that's what
our kids are going to have one day
grandkids are going to have one day when
we're dead yeah
think about that all the time that is
emotional it's on the Forefront of my
brain all the time that is so and I
remember I loved my grandfather my
especially on my mother's side and I
remember you know really listening to
him I I I really when he died I remember
having no regrets I remember I said man
I spent and I'm gonna feel the same way
about my father I spent so much time
with them and I and I spend real time
with them and you know because a lot of
people don't get that in life a lot of
people don't have a father or they don't
have time they don't get that chance so
and I'm aware of that and you know
that's one of the things that no matter
what I know when when my father goes
I'll know that I'll know that I spent
you know all that quality time but to
have that recorded oh my God are you
kidding me no oh right are you kidding
you know every man they say that most
men and women who are history directly
significant all of them kept a diary of
some kind all of them almost all of them
wrote something every day which I didn't
know but I read that recently and but
you know podcasting you know I've been
doing this now for I don't know how many
years it's just a record man it's a
record I said a lot of [ __ ] but you
know have you ever watched have you ever
watched a movie
hear me out the question have you ever
watched the same movie back to back in
four hours
ah yes what movie I mean for me it was
Raging Bull I thought you were going to
say porn but yes that as well I had to
watch that again I liked some of your
work too the mail on mail stuff no that
was Adam yeah
okay okay yeah oh Adam what a voice
right I love it
Raging Bull yeah and uh I recently
watched Stutz uh twice but that's a
different thing yeah Vinnie you got one
a movie you watch same movie do you know
how you put a song on repeat and it
keeps playing playing Good Fellas I
watched I could do the whole movie good
I've watched over and over and over and
over again have you watched the same
movie two times in four hours same movie
one thousand percent which one Good
Fellas you've watched it I've it's
disgusting I don't know if you've ever
done this before number one anything
with Vince Vaughn and then shout out to
Brian Callan The Hangover I could watch
that thing bang bang bang bang bang bang
you know what it is for me for me it's
the judge okay it's the only movie I've
watched
really watch the judge the backpack back
on a flight back from Europe I just
watched it and it's done I wondered
about them came back I watched it why
what was it about it oh my God it's the
verdict change in the second one first
of all Robert Downey Jr to me
you know how you said intuition and you
were talking about women have intuition
I think it's also for me it would be
people who have seen a lot or gone
through a lot of [ __ ] typically have
intuition I just you know I can't use
the word love with actors
but I can say I love this guy man the
way the guy acts and you know when he
went through his mess and he came back
the Redemption I mean he's just such a
so you're watching this movie and I was
telling the uh you who we're talking to
today I don't want to name drop you know
our friend uh JP JP yeah Entourage uh uh
we're talking to him and you know what I
said you know when you played Entourage
Ari you were not acting I said I I
believe you were that guy you know
Robert Downey Jr did an act in this
movie it was him it was him and Robert
Duvall was his father I've had JP help
me on acting roles he's the guy is sick
you want to talk about a guy who
understands freaking Aid that guy he
because he his mother was an acting
teacher his father was an acting teacher
do you know that of course yeah
and his sisters also Sheriff yeah she's
also done she's married to Adam McKay
right oh wow
directed you know talented at night
[Music]
yeah but he's uh yeah that guy
understands acting on a deep no no she's
something else but I'm watching this
movie so there's a there's a scene in
there where the youngest brother is like
an autistic kid you know he's got
something that he's dealing with Downs
not down syndrome but he's dealing with
something and he shows an old clip
because the oldest brother I don't know
if you guys have seen this movie or not
have you seen a movie have you ever seen
this movie bro first of all whatever you
do on the flight back figure out a way
to watch this on your phone I'm telling
you you're going to be blown away by
this man I am not he said is it a new
movie oh no no it's an older movie I'm
just old yeah if you're you're a movie
guy you're gonna be blown away by it I
can't believe I'm here bro it's such a
sick
that is a judge him and his dad have the
biggest falling out he leaves the small
City to go become one of the biggest
lawyers in all of America then his
mother dies he is forced to come back to
his mom's funeral and him and his dad
have the biggest Feud because that The
Three Brothers the two have the same
personality him dad and himself wow and
so much is revealed because the oldest
brother was a pitcher he was about to go
into major leagues there's an accident
his arm gets hurt doesn't go into the
major leagues and the youngest brother
one day they're in the basement he's
playing the old video clips of the
brothers throwing the ball and he's
doing this and he's doing that and then
the youngest brother plays a clip of the
oldest brother's car accident damn the
dad gets upset throws it turn that [ __ ]
off turn that [ __ ] off turn it off I
told you turn it off then he breaks the
camera I mean it's a very very don't
tell me anymore yeah I don't want to
tell you but I'm just telling you but by
the way I will watch this movie over and
over again you know what I like to do
with this movie I like to watch this
movie with people for the first time and
just watch their reaction I love I do
this is that movie I like to watch this
movie with people just to see how you
react to it do you know what young actor
used to look up to Robert Duvall and
mimic him who do you think it was a
young actor you talking about yourself
well that's for sure but no not Tom
Cruise Robert De Niro really De Niro's
he he Brando and Duvall they used to
watch it was De Niro and
somebody else but they used to watch
Duvall if you ever watched scenario if
you watch watched in there when he
laughs you know he does that yeah that
thing oh that's such a Duvall thing
watch Duvall yeah watch Duvall you're
right in his earlier movies yeah that
came from Duvall wow when you watch the
great Santini and he's drunk and he's
going you know the great have you seen
the great Santini that's that bro he has
to watch that Pat
that's about that's about a father and a
son relationship you got to get that
under your belt the great Santini Robert
Duvall done forget it done and I put the
judge in my mind I gotta see this I
can't wait but you know what's crazy too
as an actor and you know I and I'm a
movie buff and he knows this I've never
even heard of The Judge first I swear to
God 2014. so so I so listen I went to
The Breakers and I see Robert Duvall I I
go to him I say hey Robert can I just
tell you something he says what's that I
said in Iran we watched Godfather in
Farsi I said you have to subscribe a
suit let me tell you my experience when
I went to Iran he started telling me
these stories ah I'm like we have a
picture to get I'm like you know some
people like you see celebrities you're
like whatever you interview all these
people I was like dude you're Robert
Duvall holy you're not just standing
you're just your rapper Duvall right
when you see that so but when you watch
the judge I'm like dying to tell you how
to move against but I'm not gonna do it
to you I'm gonna I'm gonna watch it
tonight dude I had Sylvester Stallone
read Rocky he read the script like I'm
standing there with him and he's reading
from the original screenplay oh my God
I'm right there he's reading when was it
where was this well I I also I also am
there with him in his foyer when Sugar
Ray Leonard and I have it on video Sugar
Ray Leonard is showing me how because I
say to him I go champ I'm gonna ask you
because we I go not to bother you but we
were all talking and I go when I'm bot
when I'm I when I'm jab when I'm going
when I try to go here and then I go here
and I'm going for the body if I'm gonna
hit the body when I make this transition
I keep getting hit because that was true
I just couldn't I couldn't hunt the body
I realized I could pop up and as you're
turning you get hit right so I go how do
you how do you dig to the body I'm
asking him so he starts teaching me he
starts teaching me
Stallone says to my right there there it
is oh [ __ ] look look look at this look
at this look it's slow
come on come on dude dude you I have no
business asking him this [ __ ] anyway
but seriously Who Am I who is this kid
seriously what the fighter for the kid
look at me look at him teaching me
so what a moment dude where are you guys
that's in Storm's house holy crap yeah
that's that's
crazy
is that one of his daughters by the way
yeah great girls yeah I bet
dude by the way he's 60. that's that's
surreal right there but Sugar Ray and
then and then I had the same experience
with with Pacino in The what the hell is
going on dude
whose birthday was it February 3rd we
were just watching I think we were
watching the either we were watching oh
Joshua or the Super Bowl yeah that's the
Super Bowl well I would go to his house
periodically yeah yeah and so it'd be
I'd be there and I'd be like oh and then
Pacino would walk in and then David
Blaine then Guy Fieri's in the kitchen
making food and we're all hanging out
and I was like we've arrived have you
seen you know what this is he won the
Oscar when he won the Oscar and who who
creeped up on him behind him when he won
it for Rocky he's seen that where Ali
comes right behind him yeah oh that was
great yeah moment yeah man it was it's
really those moments are kind of like at
one point I was standing in a circle
with it was I think it was
Schwarzenegger Pacino Stallone and
somebody else and I'm just standing
there listening to them talk and Bill
Burr walks by me and where the cigar he
goes you've been here an hour already
get over it
and I was like no I'm not gonna get over
it this is exciting to me dude by the
way bill is uh uh one of my favorite
favorite uh comedians is Bill Burr we
have my show but I understand no I
appreciate it yeah but you know
it doesn't matter it's not about me
that was so quick I almost missed very
hard for over an hour come to Danny
improv this week yeah so Danny improv
tonight tomorrow two shows tomorrow two
shows Saturday come get some what time
tonight is eight o'clock right now eight
o'clock so we gotta get you out there we
got 45 minutes tomorrow 7 30 and then
we're doing it you're doing it again
Saturday wouldn't you leave you leave
Sunday what time you leaving Sunday I
don't think till like 5 30 uh at night
what air what airport are you leaving
from londondale or Miami I'm flying on
Beyonce's chat
they're paying you bro yeah I know and
honestly talk to a lawyer never again
will we pay you a hundred thousand
dollars when you come here that's got to
be at least a million dollar bill it's
an outrage but but I love you very
discipline I love you I want to
represent you let me be your lawyer dude
let me be your manager but David
management
from prostitutes to Comedians and this
is what I'm
you let me negotiate first yeah and then
when they hit me with their their terms
I go like this I go guys
you got to talk to the Assyrians
the door rolls up
I just don't
don't
know
and then Pat walks in like this and goes
you gotta Vlog yeah
guys I'll be over here if you need any
help by the way like if they're like you
know jobs that you wonder if you could
do or not yeah yeah are there any jobs
you're like if there is a job I wouldn't
mind seeing if I could have been good at
it or not what is the one thing you
think you would have been good if you
would have done it yeah honestly teacher
or a dancer I know it sounds like the
strip like it's a dancer like
I mean I mean yeah I got a nice ass but
still man
up here
the audience perspective so teacher or
dance yeah how about yourself like if
you did something else outside of your
comedy or Insurance what would it be
like you're like I think I would have
done a good job at that something in
music radio exec or music exact
something in music you know what I can
actually see that how about yourself
mine I have two of them one was uh like
detective because I was like my mom
watched all those shows with like blood
and I figured it out yeah but then I
wanted to be F-16 pilot easily could
have been I think you're an amazing
stand-up comic thank you and I think
you're way better than anybody knows and
I think you're better than you know I
think you're I think your talent is uh
prodigious uh I like using big words
meaning your talent is [ __ ] huge and
I think if you uh decide to be great
that's a decision we talked about this
life yeah in The Green Room I'm saying
it on the podcast because I took him
over in the green room I go Hey listen
dude you got to take yourself really
seriously you can make a choice you got
to decide if you want to be great or you
want to be you know because this guy can
do this I mean if this guy
um he could do if he took it put his
mind to it and he's done it but I mean
you you could write an hour that people
would be like what is going on here you
kill rooms dude and you know I've seen
you do it you could do that for an hour
anytime and your your talent is crazy
for building up we agree yeah so you
were gonna say well you could say pilot
16 and bye I love you thank you brother
uh it means a lot coming from you oh f60
bro because think about it I played Top
Gun and Nintendo I was disgusting at it
nasty and I was like and I was like well
if I just learned the I go live in a
pilot easy like F-16 and I was in the
Air Force too so by the way Callan happy
upcoming birthday to you buddy your
birthday's in like six days now sure it
sure is like it's 30 33 years old yeah
YouTube
Aquarius
happy birthday Sam happy birthday baby
we got the the ladies that we were
talking about from the world economic
Forum to come for his birthday there it
is there it is they're working on their
education yeah they need help with their
rent yes and we gotta we got them at a
discount Master negotiator we got help
for way cheaper than 27. okay anyways
guys this was freaking awesome awesome
uh dude have a killer show okay
go out there uh spend money you order
your drinks bring friends Dania Beach
let's put the link below people know
what it is just put the link below so
people will know as well
and then let me go to doing this again
next time
appreciate you yes have a great weekend
everybody take care bye bye bye